tour et la grande finale donc deè set
entre West leso et Magnus Carlsen hier
Magnus Carlsen c'était imposé 2 point
demi 1 et demi il mène donc 1 7 à0 et
donc pour ce match retour West les est
blanc et il entame par son petit coup B3
comme il l'avait fait hier sur quoi
Magnus avait joué lui G6 on verra s'il
répète la même variante s'il a révisé et
cetera en tout cas West emplo ce coup
pour la 3è fois avec des positions
intéressantes à chaque
fois
donc Magnus qui réfléchi un peu bien sûr
tous les coups sont bons dessus que ce
soit
D55 G6 comme il a fait ou cavalier F6
bon d' il va faire c F6 maintenant jouer
C4 est-ce qu'il va jouer le même coup ou
G3 double tout de suite ou peut-être
prise pour changer la structure même si
je suis pas trop fan du coup il joue G3
cette fois donc il Ava pas joué ceou je
vous rappelle il avait joué C4 mais le
double fet est intéressant contre ce
contre ce setup des Noirs donc les Noirs
font F G7 on fait F G2 et les Noirs bon
bah peuvent jouer D6
ou C5 alors il a fait C4 avant fou G2
pourquoi pas
euh coup qui contrôle le centre C4 bien
sûr donc les ns peuvent roquer
tranquille ou peut-être jouer D6 dans
l'optique de jouer avec E5 ensuite euh
il peut aussi peut-être jouer C5 direct
Magnus moi personnellement je pense que
j'urai le coup D6 ici
euh bon simplement déjà parce que moi je
suis un joueur dest indienne donc ça va
dans ce que je en général et puis bon
ben je veux dire aussi que si je peux
mettre un pion en facee de ce fou je
suis content parfois même jouer avec C5
pour tout bien museler au
centre Magnus qui aquet bon de toute
façon il fallait bien faire T ou tard
fou j'ai de
jouet et on va voir le schéma que Magnus
veut mettre en place donc D6 logique C5
logique je pense ça sera un des deux
coups il a jouer D6 donc si les blancs
veulent lutter contre l'apparition d'
pion ici il peut jouer avec D4 il peut
aussi faire c F3 laisser faire Rocket et
jouer bah comme une Anglaise quoi
euh donc à
voir si c'est ainsi que Wesla a prévu de
jouer c'est son choix à lui de voir le
le voilà le setup qui veut mettre en
place pour lutter contre ce que met en
place
Magnus j'ai l'impression que je joueraai
plutôt pour D4 avec les blancs mais
comme je vous dis qu' F3 c'est sûrement
jouable il E5 et il y aurait petit rock
euh ça serait une sorte de de cenne
fermée inversée d'anglaise quoi donc euh
voilà mais en général souvent ce que les
Blancs aiment bien faire c'est jouer
des4 pour si5 prendre alors en général
ça ne gagne pas un pion par ce cavalier
peut bouger et il y a un clouage long de
la diagonale et les bah les n pouront
regagner le pion mais euh mais c'est pas
très grave al il a joué au 3 qui
temporise quelque part
euh bon pourquoi pas j'ai envie de dire
mais euh bah les Noirs disons je pense
peuvent jouer au 5 sans problème ils ont
jouer des6 pour ça et euh et puis ils
sont pas gênés pour le faire donc voilà
bah c'est choses faites par de la part
de
Carlsen qui joue 5 cavalier de coup de
développement du cavalier ici et
maintenant au noir devoir alors souvent
on aime bien mettre un pion C6 pour
contrarier la vue de ce fou G2 il est un
peu moins de de puissance jusqu'en
jusque jusqu'en A8 B7 tout ça qui tape
moins et C6 aussi on peut parfois
vouloir jouer avec D5 donc C6 c'est un
coup plus ou moins logique après on peut
aussi jouer un coup tour 8 pour
continuer un peu à se développer
pourquoi pas k des7 euh plein plein
d'options mais bon moi j'iraai
volontiers pour un coup comme C6 euh C6
donc qui bloque le fou G2 et qui
préparera D5 alors bien sûr faudra
défendre ce pion de 5 qui est en
vis-àvis du Fou B2 mais un coup comme C6
puis tour8 puis D5 ça para être un plan
assez logique côté noir puisque les
Blancs ne mettent pas de pion au centre
pourquoi pas le faire côté noir et et
s'emparit donc de ce de ce centre alors
on me demande pourquoi il y a pas de
deuxième match
entre Magnus et Westley ben c'est le
deuxème match enfin quelque part deème
match la deuxème manche du même match
mais le deuxè set il y a déjà eu un
match hier remporté donc par Carlsen qui
mène un 7 à0 mais là c'est le deuxè set
alors aujourd'hui Westley doit s'imposer
pour égaliser un partout et se donner
peut-être le de jouer le match décisif
un petit peu plus tard dans la soirée
par contre si Magnus venait à nouveau
s'imposer il l'emporterait 2 70 et
serait le grand vainqueur de ce champion
chest tour 2023 il emportera la coquette
somme de 200000
dollars plus tout ce qu' aur remporté
auparavant donc une belle opération
financière et un titre de prestige pour
le Norvégien un de plus j' envie de
dire mais on en est pas là puisque
Wesley peut encore venir peut-être dans
le match il a montré ses intentions ses
vdit d'ailleurs en jouant le coupe B3 au
premier coup et euh et il est en forme
dans ce tournoi hier c'était assez serré
quand même il y a eu que de et demi 1 et
demi pour Magnus qui euh voilà qui
s'imposait vraiment de justesse donc on
peut on peut espérer peut-être un
retournement de situation au moins
peut-être une égalisation de de westle
dans un premier temps euh mais
évidemment c'est toujours difficile il
faudra quand même arriver à battre
Magnus au moins une fois et on sait que
c'est quelque chose de
délicat tour 8 a été joué par par le
Norvégien tour 8 donc coup de placement
à la tour qui qui vient surprotéger ce
pion surtout dans l'optique de jouer
avec D5 donc j'imagine volontier jouer
avec C6 D5 comme je disais aaravant euh
k C3 joué par Westley qui se développe
et voilà bah un coup comme CCI ça a
l'air très raisonnable pour les Noirs
euh ben voilà c'est
joué c'est joué par Magnus alors est-ce
que Wesley va roquer est-ce qu'il va
jouer D4 avant que les Noirs a eu le
temps de jouer D5 eux même ou est-ce
qu'il va temporisé avec un coup comme
peut-être tour C1 ou que sais-je
euh D4 semble quand même assez logique à
un moment ou à un autre
euh le problème de Rocket en fait c'est
que une fois qu'on aura fait un coup
comme D5 et souvent il y a un échange et
qu'on joue D4 parce qu'on peut pas
laisser tout le centre gratuit c'est
deux pion qui peuvent avancer à tout
moment qu'on fait des4 et qu' a E4 il y
a quand même une possibilité d'attaque
pour les Noirs hein contre ce ce rock
blanc puisque on sait que cette
structure avec les pions E3 et G3
notamment ne fait pas forcément toujours
bon ménage avec des trous ici ou là
alors pour l'instant c'est bien couvert
il y a pas trop de souci mais si on
imagine une structure comme ça pour les
Noirs à un moment voilà ça peut ça peut
clignoter ici le fou pourrait venir il
pourrait avoir des échanges des
manœuvres de cavalier via H7 G5 pour
rentrer et euh donc ça pourrait devenir
inquiétant à un moment euh c'est
pourquoi je patienterai un peu avant de
Rocket et peut-être jou un coup comme D4
dans un premier temps alors vous me
direz oui mais on peut aussi jouer avec
4 mais à ce moment là on peut voir avec
les avec les Blancs et pas forcément
roquet il peut peut-être même jouer un
coup comme H3 avec l'idée de faire G4
mettre le Caval en G3 pour mettre une
pression là-dessus pourquoi pas bouger
la dame faire grand rock et aller
attaquer par ici alors bon il en
faudrait un peu pour en arriver là mais
c'est un scénario qu'on pourrait
envisager euh c'est un qui serait pas
possible si on Requet trop vite donc
donc voilà je serai partisant du coup D4
ici alors il y a Ewa Spirit qui demande
le meilleur conseil qu'on pourrait
donner à une personne qui souhaite
s'améliorer aux échecs et qui est 850 ho
bah écoute déjà faudrait que tu tu joues
un petit peuin amuse-toi et puis et puis
essaye bah je sais pas la chaîne Blitz
stream facile est peut-être pas mal avec
des petits conseils de regarder des
vidéos euh tu peux aussi suivre un peu
des des essayer de te trouver de la des
livres faire des exercices
euh et puis puis petit à petit ça
devrait monter en puissance euh mais au
début je te conseille pas d'apprendre
trop de théorie par cœur mais juste
d'essayer de comprendre ce que tu fais
et
euh et de jouer en comprenant et petit à
petit ça va
monter alors finalement Wesley qui a
joué E4 euh E4 donc bah il veut vraiment
lutter contre D5 alors il a joué E3 puis
E4 c'est en deux temps donc forcément
c'est un peu lent mais en même temps on
peut on peut comprendre aussi peut-être
son mode de penser c'estàd qu'à l'époque
si ici il avit jouer avec E4 ça aura
vraiment affaibli cette case vous allez
me rétorquer oui bon on a la partie ça
affaibli tout autant la case sauf que
entreemps il y a eu ce pion C6 qui a
paru chez noir donc le cavalier mettra
plus de temps venir dessus donc c'est
sûrement ça l'idée de de westle c'est de
ok je suis affaibli je peux courvrir en
mettant des 4 peut-être
mais en même temps pour c'est pas si
simple de venir dessus trop vite Magnus
qui jou à 6 donc il veut jouer avec avec
B5 dans la foulée pour venir un peu
prendre de l'espace à mais attaquer la
chaîne de pion des blancs mettre un pion
ici et puis pourquoi pas le F6 en B7
pour quand même jouer des5 plus tard et
de toute façon avec le pion B5 qui cette
tension sur C4 et peut-être aussi
parfois faire B4 pour chasser celui-là
et avoir des5 dans la
foulée
donc
donc à voir si les blancs veulent
empêcher B5 on pourrait songer au coup
A4 mais que j'aime pas trop alors
pourquoi j'aime pas parce que les Noirs
pourrai perdre un temps à faire A5 mais
sauf que après ils aura accès à cette ce
B4 et aussi à la ce C5 pour le cavalier
on a plus de coup de pion avec le pion B
pour l'enlever et MD4 on se ferait
échanger donc ça affaiblira vraiment les
cases noires de jouer ainsi pour ça
qu'en fait un coup comme A4 qui semble
logique de prime bord si on se dit ah
tiens il veut faire ça je l'empêche oui
mais je l'empêche à quel prix bah au
prix que je je détruis mes cases noires
donc ok au moins il a il a résou on va
dire le problème dont je vous parlais
avec E4 et tout ça avec ses casses
faibles mais mais du coup il se fait
attaquer de l'autre côté donc est-ce
qu'il va quand même jouer avec D4 il va
être plus conservateur à faire un coup
comme D3 pour tenir son centre et puis
préparer F4 de l'autre côté c'est
possible
aussi à
avir voilà c'est des positions assez
souples un peu on appelle ça le
formation bodvinique c'est de
enfin c'est trois pions comme ça en V
alors le pion il pas encore en D3 mais
si jamais il venait à le mettre
ici il peut aussi vraiment jouer avec D4
qui semble pourquoi pas possible je sais
pas ce qu'il est en tête mais Magnus une
autre fois qui a bien géré l'ouverture
il pas vraent été mis en difficulté par
par ce B3 de saut et Magnus qui sait
bien placer ses pièces on le sait c'est
une ses qualités évidemment
et qui retombe bien sur ses pieds à3
simplement de West
donc jeu d'attente pour l'instant de de
Westley il voulait peut-être pas laisser
un coup comme B4 et il laisse un peu
l'initiative du joue à son
adversaire en mettant en place sa
position petit à petit en tissant sa
toile j'ai envie de dire on va
voir alors Bogdan demande qui a remporté
la manche d'hier c'était Carlsen Carlsen
qui mène une manche à zé mais tout reste
encore possible mais pour là il faudrait
que Westley gagne ce match
aujourd'hui BD7
jouer bon qui BD7 hein donc un coup de
développement ce cavalier peut rebondir
vers B6 vers C5 vers F8 très
raisonnable on va voir ce que Westley
joue il fait D3 donc voilà il fait cette
formation bodvinique j'en parlais et
donc souvent bah c'est soit pour jouer à
dame mais bon maintenant ça a l'air un
peu compromis puisque bah les Noirs ont
déjà pris l'initiative de ce côté mais
bon probablement il va essayer de jouer
avec F4 peut-être F5 et d'attaquer à
l'roi alors on verra petit à petit
comment il va pvoir mettre ça en place
tour B8 jouer tour B1 donc tour B1 bah
probablement pour surprotéger le fou et
se préparer à l'ouverture de la colonne
B si jamais les Noirs venaient à prendre
là c'estra que s'il prenait on aurait
pas pu prendre du pion B vu qu'il y av s
B2 en prise alors bon on pour encore
prendre de d mais mais je pense que
Wesley préféit prendre comme ça garder
une sorte de symétrie dans les pions et
se préparer lutter contre cette colonne
B donc pourquoi pas
TB en tout cas les Noirs s'ils veulent
vraiment jouer pour des5 je pense qu'il
pourra jouer fou B7 ramener un fou ici
donc il sera muré par ses propres pions
mais pour préparer la poussée D5 puisque
le fou travaillera à distance pour le
contrôle de cette
case et euh et c'est pas
bête bon il pourra aussi peut-être jouer
un coup de cavalier comme cavalier F8
ou ou ailleurs pour euh ouvrir la
diagonale du fou et venir vers vers e 6
par exemple hein beaucoup de coups
possibles pour les Noirs euh qui ont
l'air très correct et
raisonnable donc on va voir ce que
Magnus compte faire mais il est pas mis
en danger en tout cas je répète dans
cette ouverture cela dit tout reste
possible c'est une partie qui se décante
petit à
petit
mais wesle assez fan finalement de son
son B3 au premier coup qu' l'emploie à
plusieurs reprises il avait un petit peu
annoncé hein sur Twitter
mais on va dire que ça n'engage à
rien mais déjà troisème fois qu'il
emploiss cette petite ouverture entre le
la finale et la demi-finale donc k C5
joué par Magnus donc il replace le
cavalier
ici on peut le chasser mais de toute
façon le cavalier pourrait rebouger et
notamment vers e6in c'est c'est sûrement
une bonne case pour ce cavalier comme on
l'a mentionné avant cette case est un
peu affaiblie en D4 et donc le cavalier
en E6 a euh et a un pied de d'aller vers
D4 donc donc donc pas bête bon sa qui a
fait fou bonment pour se protéger mais
il fait beaucoup de coup de défense he
pas de menace pour l'instant chez lui
euh peut-être un peu mou de jouer de la
sorte donc on va voir si Magnus revient
ave ce cavalier en E6 bien sûr il a
d'autres options il pourrait peut-être
même songer un coup comme fou
G4 pourquoi pas si le fou était chassé
on pourrait l'échanger contre ce
cavalier 2 parce que on veut échanger
les pièces blanches qui aident au
contrôle importantes des qu alors il a
joué B prancais he euh ce qui est
intéressant aussi puisque j'imagine que
Wesley aimerait prendre comme ça vu
comment il a joué jusqu'àors mais à ce
moment-là il aurait plus l'occasion de
chasser ce serait complètement installé
là en C5 euh alors que s'il fait
desessai il garde cette option mais il a
eu donné l'impression de pas jouer pour
cette structure cela dit je préférerais
limite he pour lui de prendre comme ça
maintenant euh et puis essayer de jouer
le long de la colonne D vers ce pion et
atttaquer petit à petit alors ce sera
pas forcément simple hein les ns de
toute façon peuvent le blinder ils ont
eux aussi une cible le long de la
colonne B si c'est ça le le choix de de
Westley on verra euh non mais il a pris
de B donc bah comme je disais he ça
donnait l'impression qu'il voulait jouer
de la sorte vu tous les coups qu'il a
joué auparavant donc il a repris comme
ça mais le défaut voilà c'est que ce
cavalier maintenant est vraiment
installé en C5 sur une belle case on a
plus de coup de pion pour le chasser on
aurait des4 certes mais de toute façon
on peut toujours échanger côté noir et
ça faitblir4 donc j'aime pas pas trop ce
que fait Westley il est un peu en en
difficulté il se fait un peu out player
comme on dit en anglais euh c'est
dominer quoi on va dire
dans dans ses manœuvres dans tout ce qui
se passe pour l'instant alors il reste
dans une position assez solide hein mais
il met vraiment pas en danger son
adversaire et
euh c'est même lui hein qui qui doit
surveiller deux trois trucs dans la
position bah notamment ce pion un peu
faible alors pour l'instant il a la dame
qui le défend mais
mais il a pas de gros plan avec les
Blancs pour pour changer la Danne pour
l'instant F 6 donc il se développe il se
développe et comme je disais il a
peut-être envie de jouer D5 par la
suite donc c'est logique hein il sort sa
dernière pièce qui qui était pas
développée le fonc vite hop il vient se
mettre au milieu et ça pourrait aussi
permettre peut-être à la tour de passer
là-bas sur la colonne B bah la la seule
colonne ouverte de chiqu où pourrait y
avoir un combat donc un coup comme dame
C7 avec l'intention de jouer tour là ça
peut être intéressant bon W bien jouer
tour D1 bon il se prototège il veut
peut-être jouer D4 un jour
mais pas simple hein pour l'instant euh
non mais il souffre un peu mais c'est
important qu'il perde pas cette partie
parce que là il se mettra vraiment dans
le dur pour la suite comme je vous le
rappelle he faut absolument gagner ce
match alors il est même pas obligé de le
gagner directement il pourrait faire de
deux et gagner l'ARM gedon
mais
mais bon ça sent pas trop bon quand on a
les blancs et de déjà suer ds la
première partie comme ça alors per ça
sera encore
pire faut tenir quoi dame B8 pas bête de
la part de Magnus qui ve changer les
dames et prendre aussi possession de la
colonne comme je le mentionnait cette
colonne
ouverte qui a qui un trempelin vers le
camp adverse et ce serait lui qui
pourrait l'obtenir si échangend de la
tour et la tour pour directement venir
vers B3 attaquer par ici par là ATT
attention au
danger
alors le bon banjo demande je voulais
savoir qu'est-ce qui se passe pour les
Reza et les candidats et ben pour
l'instant il est pas du tout qualifié il
est même assez loin
euh sa seule chance si voulait se
qualifier serait d'esser de jouer des
des parties longues d'ici la fin de
l'année et de gagner des points ho alors
il est inscrit aucun tournoi à ce que je
sache mais bon si si si S mouche le
piquet de jouer il aura le droit et et
qui sait il faudrait qu'il gagne
peut-être 6 7 7 points ho je crois 7 8
euh pour passer devant West leso West
leso lui je l'imagine pas jouer mais
intercaler aussi l'enard Dominguez le le
joueur ancien joueur cubain maintenant
américain qui joue en ce moment même au
un tournoi en Espagne à CJS et euh mais
c'est difficile pour lui de gagner des
points il espère en gagner au moins un
ou deux sur le tournoi pour hop passer
devant Westley mais euh mais c'est un
tour difficile et il a déjà lâché une
nul qui lui a coûté donc pour l'instant
il perd plutôt des points mais le tour
n'étant pas fini on sait jamais il peut
il peut mettre l'accélération mais euh
je suis un peu pessimiste pour les
chances de de Dominguez dans dans ce
tournoi de de de gagner des points ho
mais toujours est-il donc pour l'instant
en tout cas fouja n'est pas du tout au
candidat il faudrait qu' voilà qu'il se
décide de jouer d'ici la fin de l'année
euh bon alors il y aura pas de grands
tournois mais il peut aller jouer des
petits tournois jouer des adversaires
très mal classé mais gagner 08 par 08
les points ho et puis bah monterin c'est
c'est possible et c'est
légal donc on verra s'il se décide pour
faire un truc comme ça donc W en tout
cas qui n'a pas échangé les dames qui a
fait dam C2 plutôt logique de pas avoir
une tour débarqué tout de suite en B8
mais dam B3 voilà bah c'est joué
pourrait arriver pour quand même forcer
cet échange libérer la CE pour la tour
et et commencer à se fauxfiler dans le
camp blanc donc
attention
toujours aussi difficile
pour pour Westley et donc Kevin en fait
ça va il est il est ici mais mais il a
deux trois trucs à régler euh il pourra
passer dans un petit moment alors
peut-être pas pour cette partie mais
j'imagine peut-être pour la suivante
enfin on verra il est il est pas loin et
et vous inquiétez pas pour
lui ouais position donc difficile he
pour esle comme je disais il aurait aimé
mettre sous pression Carlsen mais c'est
pas du tout ce qui se passe et c'est à
lui de défendre et vient de jouer dame
C1 il veut pas l'échange des dames mais
donc bah il est très passif he
simplement ça se
voit si on compare la position il y a un
trou ici chez les Blancs il no non il y
a le pion qui couvre il y a un cavalier
qui est plutôt bien placé une dame qui
est rentré il y a le contrôle de la
colonne B donc si on compare juste pièce
par pièce et détail par détail tout euh
tout est est plutôt supérieur pour les
ns donc forcément ils sont mieux après
bien sûr faut encore convertir c'est pas
comme s'il avait une grosse avance
matérielle ou quoi mais euh mais une
position sympa euh je sais pas il
pourrait jouer tour B8
peut-être h peut-être reculer sa dame
pour libérer le cavalier pour rentrer
par
ici il a il a différentes idées même
sans rien jouer de spécial je sais pas
trop quel est quel est le plan des
blancs qu'est-ce qu'il peuvent mettre en
en place donc même passer son tour
serait une option pour les Noirs j'ai
envie de dire
mais mais ouais plutôt bien Magnus on va
voir comment il essaie de convertir ça
je pense qu'il aimerait gagner he mettre
directement un petit coup de bambou sur
la tête de son
adversaire et filer vers la victoire
finale dans ce ce champion che
tour bon écoute merci mat Ben qui qui
est content des des commentaires bah je
fais ce que je peux hein en
meuble soupamox qui se souviens que
j'avais fait deux vidéos sur B3 et ouais
sur le je pense j'avais fait sur le
Youtube de chesscom France mais il y a
quelques années j'avais fait des
articles couplés à ça c'était pas
tellement pour l'aspect théorique
théorique même si j'essayé un peu de
décortiquer ce qui se passe mais c'était
pour expliquer un peu comment se
construire un répertoire euh
et voilà je pense c'est toujours
dispo pour ceux que ça intéresse alors
Magnus qui a joué cavalier fd7
euh pas bête c'est pas un coup que
j'avais mentionné mais évidemment
intéressant dans le sens où ça peut
libérer le pion F pour jouer peut-être
un coup comme F5 et aussi euh si Jama à
un moment il entreprend une manœuvre en
bougeant ce cavalier pour venir vers D4
ça libérerait la C C5 pour le deuxème
cavalier qui viendrait le le relayer sur
cette jolie ce C5
donc donc ça ça travaille bien les
pièces noires elles sont c'est
harmonieux wle qui joue des4 bon ben il
en a marre en fait euh il en a marre de
subir et enfin il fait un coup vers
l'avant le premier de la partie j'ai
envie de dire au 20e coup
euh bon alors bien sûr il se retrouve
avec euh des faiblesses ici ou là hein
notamment ce pion C4 maintenant mais Mo
il attaque la dame il attaque
C6 et si euh les Noirs venaient à
prendre euh en C4 bon alors faud
regarder si F1 ce serait pas possible
déjà ça a l'air he pour pour enfermer la
dame donc dame prend on va dire que
c'est pas tellement jou enfin je pas je
me questionne enfin je veux dire F F1 je
vois que la dame elle elle est en PLS
mais peut-être qu'on peut jouer un
sacrifice de dame pour avoir tour pièce
et pion et une certaine
activité c'est sûrement jouable pour les
Noirs ce genre de truc pas nécessaire
j'ai envie de dire pas nécessaire d'en
arriver là mais peut-être qu'on peut
l'envisager après l'uttion bah c'est
simplement faire foupran alors c'est
toujours dangereux en fait de se
départir d'un d'un fou du FIAN Ketto
surtout que lui il est toujours en vie
une dame peut arriver et il peut avoir
des histoires verg7 mais ça c'est à
regarder quand même parce que parce
qu'on a des pièces qui rebondissent bien
avec les noires C4 qui a l'air condamné
peut-être on peut sauter vers des TR
euh faut ouais faut investiguer ça ça
peut être très fort pour les Noirs
euh ils peuvent prendre ouais ce P C4
qui qui a l'air ais comme je dis
condamné euh euh sur tour prend bon
peut-être on prend ça peut-être on peut
venir taquiner la dame quand elle bouge
on peut prendre lui la tour peut-être
bloqué dans le camp adverse enfin ça a
l'air dangereux
euh ah Magnus dev voir euh FPR l'air
intéressant fondamentalement il peut y
avoir des problèmes à long terme avec ce
roi faible mais si concrètement on
arrive à enchaîner les coups cavalier 5
prendre C4 ou peut-être après faire fou
g4evenenir vers F3 ou quoi peut-être que
tout se met bien en place et que c'est
et que c'est très fort bon il a pris il
a fait prendre des4 après une belle
réflexion qui reprend cavali qui vient
E5 donc il joue laavante qu'on regardait
un peu on n pas regardé dans tous les
détails hein mais on voyait que ça
pouvait peut-être être être intéressant
pour les Noirs parce que donc c'est deux
CAV très bien placés le pion C4 qui est
faible la case D3 où les C peuvent venir
dessus une autre idée c'est de faire fou
G4 pour venir vers F3 donc pas mal de
possibilités pour les noirs pour jouer
sur toutes ces cases blanches que j'ai
mentionné C4 D3 F3
euh et donc la menace directe mais c'est
soit de prendre le pion soit de mettre
un cavalier en D3 faire bouger cette
dame et prendre à TR euh voilà donc le
le seul vrai gros espoir des blancs j'ai
envie de dire c'est l'ouverture de cette
longue diagonale pour faire parler ce
fou soit pour faire une batterie avec la
dame qui viendrait à un moment ou qui
irait vers H6 et et G7 Wesley qui a pris
en D6 qui a des TR jouer très vite par
Magnus qui attaque la dame et donc il
veut aller prendre ce pion à 3 euh quand
dame va bouger alors le problème pour
Wesley c'est que sur dame D1 dame prend
à3 on pourrait croire qu'on prend ici
deux fois mais le fou 1 ne serait plus
défendu donc c'est pas une option et
donc attention pour Westley situation
qui m'a l'air de d'aller de mal en pis
pour pour le joueur américain
euh position pas facile mais bon ça
pourrait peut-être tourner un moment sur
sur un malentendu cela dit il a une
minute de moins à la pendule et ça va
pas être simple he parce que il va
bouger la dame Magnus va prendre ça va
attaquer cette tour qui a pas 50 cases
hein qui va devoir aller se réfugier en
D4 il sera deux points d'être peut-être
deux points deux doigts d'être peut-être
perdu euh on va voir ça se passe pas
trop bien pour pour Westley en tout
cas donc l'ordi n'a pas aimé dame D1 bon
peut-être qu'il serait allé en B1 qu'
aurait joué autre chose mais bon peu
importe c'est pas c'est pas encore perdu
pour autant mais euh situation
délicate très délicate pour wley
ouais pris en à3 et C5 jeis par Westley
donc a priori l'ordi n'aime pas non plus
il aurait voulu reculer la tour bon
c'était pas brillant deuler la tour on
le sait parce que ce pion pouvait tomber
ou quoi mais euh il a joué C5 il espère
avir dame prendre C5 pour faire tour
prendre D3 j'imagine mais euh ouais ça a
l'air très très friable sa
position ça tient un
fil ça tient un
fil je sais pas pour combien de temps al
fou B3 jouer attaque la dame la dame qui
peut pas quitter cette première rangée
hein puisqu'il faut défendre il faut
défendre ce fou il faut défendre ce fou
donc ça être dame B1 dame F1 je sais pas
par
là-bas
compliqué et le problème d'ailleurs pour
pour esle c'est que disons il y a un
coup il aurait aimé voir dame pr c 5
pour prendre ici mais sur fou
il doit aller peut-être en B1 ou en F1
sur un des
deux pour garder la même idée mais
peut-être il y a ce coup qui commence à
être possible l'idée c'est d'attirer le
roi et pour faire dame pr et double
attaque j'ai l'impression qu'en fait il
y a pas de bon coup parce que sur dame
F1 c'est la même punition étant donné
que dame PR est pas possible parce que
il y aurait le FO pas protéger donc donc
ça se passe très mal en fait
pour se fait balayer en fait on do dire
cette partie
il a joué un peu trop passif je trouve à
mon goût il a fait dame F1 on va voir si
ça marche bien Sky PR2 en plus c'est
sûrement pas la seule manière de jouer
pour les pour les
Noirs mais c'est un coup qui m'a l'air
qui m'a l'air pas
mal
prioriis c'est peuttre pas le prééré de
l'ordi mais on voit que la Jae elle
bougerait pas trop sera quand même sympa
donc ça l'air de marcher quand même
prend
F2
et ouais c'est vrai qu'on parle de
l'info l'atmosphère dans la salle et
ouais on en sent qu'on est en fin de
tournoi et
que et que a eu de la transpiration dans
cette salle on sent que le CO2 est monté
l'air tout juste
passable beaucoup d'hum enfin beaucoup
pas beaucoup justement mais plus que
d'habitude quand Mme l'umidité correct
et quand même 25°gr fit chaud alors fou
C4 joué par westle il a pas all faire le
cas il prend F2 ou quoi mais fou C4 il
se met en face de la dame donc il se
garde bah il se garde un peu toutes les
découvertes possibles pour le cavalier
il se donne aussi d prend C5 en stock
s'il a envie étant donné qu'on aura plus
t reprend cavalier donc dame prend C5
euh bah ça l'air très bien c'est juste
un punto de plus pour les Noirs ça va
encore attaquer cette tour qui qui est
mal placé en fait et on s'est mis dans
un clouage enfin il y a rien qui va quoi
j'ai envie de dire euh c'est kata c'est
kata pour
Westley Magnus qui peut tranquillement
aller prendre ce pion s'il en a
envie Magnus en contrôle bon alors il y
a plus qu'une
minute on peut toujours gaffer à ce
moment-là mais il a pas l'air très
stressé et les coups en fait on va pas
dire que c'est dur quoi enfin il a
beaucoup de bonnes options c'est même
s'il joue pas le top coup de la position
il est bien quoi qu'il choisisse quoi
donc
il a pas de ma solution
Magnus vraiment séisme pour que s'impose
pas on va voir s un peu qu'il oublie un
truc en fait qu' joue un coup rép
surprise pe pque il pris viteul tour
plus Magnus cette fin de partie beaucoup
mieux mais peut-être la pendule qui va
se mêler à la lutte on va voir
c'est un bon pion de plus hein il y a
pas du tout de compensation pour les
blancs donc à voir si les noir arrive à
profiter de ce clouage il vient de jouer
dame à 3 donc il se replace plutôt bien
c'est vrai que c'est dur de bouger avec
les blans on asfixier dans cette
position j'ai j'ai pas d'idée en fait de
de quoi jouer avec les Blancs c'est on
subit littéralement ce qui se passe dans
la
position je venu la fin de la partie
parce que je suis inquiet pour le chat
ah ben ça se passe très mal hein il se
fait mais est-ce qu'on y croit encore
Fab
pas trop moi j'y crois pas trop mais bon
l'espoir c'est qu'il a 16 secondes pour
magnu c'est que peut-être une gaffe
pourrait arriver on ne sais pas comment
pourquoi où mais peut-être il FPR de
dame F1 qui en surcharge qui doit
défendre le FO il qui li 2 donc c'est la
premère menace déjà paril pour Wesley
qui souffle qui su c'est dur pour les
tu penses que la boîte de thon est en
train de s'échapper pour les chats
complètement c'est si celle les chats ça
être régime strict de
croquette trouvé une défense quand même
au moins il per pas de pièce al il a
juste son P de MO juste entre guillemets
il y a les pion passés et cetera c'est
chiant
mais jamais une petite imprécision de
[Musique]
Magnus pas si mal sorti par rapport à ce
qu'il
avait bien dégueulasse
qu'il accélère il AR faire5 c'est pas
mal il active le fou
enfin croire
pas trop rest concentré sur les
croquettes une belle surprise qui
s'annonce tant mieux
quoi c'est mal temp aussi
maintenant en plus hier Magnus qui a
mieux joué les finales que
wesle et là il est dans son élément
alors bon c'est une finale qui est pas
super technique pour le moment il y a
encore beaucoup de pièces ça peut être
fouilli tout ça on va voir c'est
peut-être pas mal là il attaque le fou
il attaque le fou il contreattaque
est-ce qu'on peut le prendre perdre
notre cavalier c'est F aussi le problème
on sa pas trop com faire attends dit que
ça peut être
égal il n a pas un cavalier D2 il fait
A4 peut-être prendre ce fou un jour il
reprend il devit peut-être une défense à
un moment donné derrière les fagot c'est
c'est de pion de
moins le pion G3 en plus ça fait mal ça
t'enlève les G4 F5 de la
position à plus ça sent les
croquettes il donne tous ses pions quoi
pas partir et faire e échec mais pas
boug même pas
F2 maintenant au
supplice F4 peut-être
ok des4 c'est beau
aussi enfin il a pu se débarrassé de son
fou mais bon au prix de pion passé de
partout qui lui arrive
dessus qui va avancer en D3 là non ils
avancent tous là ça va don tour à 2 il y
aura pas de C G3 pour le roi ah il y
avait roi E7 tour8
mat
dommage réussi à avoir une menace quand
même
E6 mon son roi juste pour éviter
allez F 3
peut-être peut-être 55 tant pis donne ce
pion allez il y a peut-être une chance
là
Fab 6 quand même allez on y croit P à
tour
F5 mais il a peut-être raté non Magnus
ro tour ah
non allez les
chats
prend ce cavalier déjà mais bon à 3 va
arriver on Deir trer pour ramener la
tour et il y aura de TR de
plus il y a rien à faire il s'est bien
battu quandme s bien
battu il
abandonne petite
pause tout à l'heure pour la deè rond
Magnus du coup qui s'envole vers finale
qui est bien parti en tout
cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ben je suis de retour en attendant
le début de la deuxième partie à mon
avis ne devrait plus trop tarder donc
Magnus qui va avoir les pièces blanches
et qui mène 1-0 dans ce match dans ce
second match donc qui a pris clairement
une option pour pour la victire de ce 7
et donc la victire de ce match euh
Magnus impérial hein qui a vraiment
dominé la tête et des épaules la partie
précédente
euh bah que faire pour Wesley pas
évident euh bon c'est sûr que sil per
celle-là c'est quasiment fini donc bah
déjà se remettre l'endroit
euh et puis peut-être tourisqu à la
prochaine parce que toute façon il
faudra bien en gagner une et c'est mieux
côté Blanque au côté noir normalement
même si on a déjà vu dans ce tournoi des
fois des joueurs avec les pièces
blanches ne pas arriver à
annuler mais la logique voudrait
voudrait une tentative quoi euh à la
prochaine mais déjà ça existe je ne pas
perdre ici donc il va falloir voilà tout
donner bien mettre les barbesbé serrer
les vis
pour pour pouvoir se donner cette
opportunité à la prochaine partie de
peut-être peut-être avoir une chance
voilà mais autant vous dire je suis pas
très optimiste pour pour
Westley pendant ce temps je vois qu'ils
sont arrivés à fixer un peu la qualité
de l'air qui est devenue bonne
et par contre par contre il fera il aura
fait chaud tout tout le long du tournoi
dans cette
salle ce match a-t-il encore du suspense
honnêtement bah écoute je viens d'y
répondre plus ou moins c'est que c'est
c'est pas fini mais c'est un suspense on
va dire relatif tant Magnus a dominé la
première et gros favori mais bah en fait
il suffit que westle en gagne une sur
les trois prochaines ça peut arriver tu
as un Armagedon l'armagedon c'est peut
se passer des choses et que bon bah en
étant dominé dans le match il reviennent
et voilà mais je pas lui donner un grand
pourcentage de chance que ça arrive mais
voilà c'est pas zéro non plus vu le
format comment ils ont construit la la
compétition et
euh et comment ça se passe tu vois tu
peux toujours revenir il te laisse en
fait la chance de pouvoir pouvoir te
remettre après on va voir comme je vous
dis celle-là il vaut mieux ne pas la
perdre pour W s veut avoir encore un
espoir parce que là s'il y avait
2-0 seulement deux parties à
rester trop peu de chance Magnus tu vas
pas lui mettre 20 comme ça déjà que là
c'est
dur
donc donc voilà voilà ce que j'en pense
donc E4 joué par Magnus C5 cavalier F3
pas d'alapine pour l'instant
D6 Wesley donc je sais pas si comp jou
une nche d'orf ou quoi en tout cas on ne
saura pas puisque Magnus joue une petite
varante avec fou C4 mais coup
intéressant au
demeurant contre 6 contre les autres
siciliennes c'est un peu moins bien
parce qu'on peut se prendre E6 D5 mais
là avec D6 on va pas avoir ce arriver si
facilement ici que j'ai joué un peu dans
ma jeunesse côté blanc se demande que
Vlad jouit Murtas jouit moroevic l'avait
employé donc D6 B on peut reculer le fou
OK ou faire C3 c'est un peu comme il
veut mais moi j'aime bien faire fou B3
petit rock C3 un truc comme ça après on
met la tour en1 le fou qui peut
revenenir en C2 et essayer de préparer
des4 petit à petit pour prendre le
centre
de la sorte ça peut être après une
position qui peut ressembler à des
Françaises la structure de pion mais à
voir comment les Noirs agencent leur
pions et leurs pièces bien sûr F 7 a été
joué wle qui se développe
tranquillement mais variantes vraiment
intéressante
quoi non ça commencé une heure plut tôt
bah non ça commencé à 18h tous les jours
Fab the Fab ça commence à 18h tous les
jours euh et là donc c'est la deuxème
partie hein c'est pas la première
d'ailleurs tu vois le score qui est bien
mis 1-0 pour Carlsen c'està dire qu'il a
gagné la partie
précédente et euh et donc Magnus qui
commence à réfléchir euh ouais moi je
sais pas le coupfou B3 me me semblerait
pas mal al il a joué à
4 ma fois pourquoi pas ça peut donner
une case au fou là-bas ça peut ralentir
des B5 à venir et euh et globalement
c'est un traitement moderne des
positions ces coups de pions euh
latéraux comme ça donc euh donc pourquoi
pas hein j'ai envie de dire ça doit pas
être si mal comme
coup D5 jouer par West là maintenant fut
B5
échec et probablement C C6 qui va venir
bon peut-être que fou D7 aussi serait un
coup j'imagine qu'il aimerait faire E5
dessus pour faire rebouger ce C F6 donc
fou des7 j'aime pas trop trop ouais
plutôt 6
peut-être et fa
F8 et fa F8 choix relativement étonnant
mais en fait j'ai l'iMon qu'il veut
essayer de fructifier sur ce fou un poil
enfermé euh bah c'est vrai que là quand
même la menace c'est à 6 hein
euh pour pour jouer contre ce fou
essayer de de l'attraper euh choix
intéressant de la part de Wesley coup
inattendu 3 F8 et euh et peut-être pas
si
mal peut-être pas si
mal surtout qu'il a joué assez vite hein
je dois dire il a pas réfléchi des
masses et ça m'étonnerait qu'il soit
trop préparé dans cette position he
westle donc décision courageuse et
intéressante de sa part on voit que ça a
surpris Magnus qui commence à réfléchir
un petit
peu
on me demande pourquoi je parlais de
traitement moderne avec ce cou A4 là
tout à l'heure bah on a vu alpha 0 hein
donc l'intelligence artificielle jouait
beaucoup avec les pions tour A4 H4
avancé par là euh et en fait en fait ça
inspiré beaucoup de joueurs bon
notamment ceux qui ont travaillé avec ce
type d'ordinateur donc qui qui est un
peu différent de tout ce qu'on avait
avant des frites des stockfish des trucs
comme ça qui étaient des des des grands
calculateurs on va dire euh et donc ça a
un peu changé la perception la manière
de voir les choses enfin ça apporté un
petit plus et donc des JS comme Carlsen
qui ont beaucoup travaillé avec ou quoi
bah ils ont peut-être pris plus
facilement le pli ils ont compris
comment ça quand est-ce ils sont inspiré
en tout cas quand est-ce que les ordis
l'utilisaient ou quoi et ils se sont mis
à voilà à le mettre à ajouter cette
corde à leur arc on va dire à leur jeu
et voilà maintenant c'est pas rare de
voir ses pions
partir donc a ou h un peu à n'importe
quel moment de la partie en éclaireur
pour pour prendre de l'espace et voilà
mais ça a du sens parce que c'est une
manière de d'activer la tour aussi le
fait de pousser un pion a contrairement
à un autre pion on va dire un pion à2
défend qu'une case en a 3 défend qu'une
case en a 4 défend qu'une case alors
qu'un autre le pion d il tient deux
cases donc c'est toujours moins
compromettant en fait un pion a ou h
parce que ça n'affaiblit qu'une case qui
peut être couverte par son homolog C
c'est le fait de pas être en A2 ça
affaiblit pas forcément la case B3 ça
fait pas forcément la case B4 par le
pion C2 pourrait venir couvrir
donc j'imagine que l'ordi a compris des
choses comme ça pour pour jouer de la
sorte quoi euh bon c G8 jouer sur E5 il
voulait pas se mettre à porter tir du
Fou et il veut toujours jouer donc pour
essayer de gagner ce fou donc maintenant
à voir si Magnus ve faire D4 pour
essayer de se rapatrier mais j'imagine
que vu comme jouo il va fermer avec C4
ou alors faire A5 pour donner la case à4
mais c'est un pion A5 qui pourrait
être perdu très prochainement j'imagine
si on fait a 5 pour avoir A6 le fou
recul et dame prend pion puis attention
parce que s'il fou à nouveau attaquer il
y a le clouage sur la tour donc ça joue
de manière entreprenante de la part de
Westley beaucoup plus que dans la
première partie peut-être risqué hein
parce qu'on voit quand même en terme de
développement il y a voilà on a fait k
F6 pour repartir en G8 on a plus drquer
ou quoi mais si on gagnait un pion avec
une structure assez fermée au centre
comme c'est le cas ici on peut digérer
le pion et petit à petit euh bah essayer
de de le digérer et l'emporter à terme
quoi donc en tout cas ça part pour la
vente qu'on a vu Wesley qui vient
prendre ce pion en A5 et
euh et voilà donc il un P de plus Magnus
qui joue C4 euh C4 donc il veut essayer
d'ouvrir un peu le jeu c'est assez
logique he quand un roi adverse est au
centre ou qu' a un avantage de
développement même si il y a pas
tellement de gros avantage de
développement des blancs mais en tout
cas les Noirs ils vont avoir du mal à
finir le développement de leur pièces
bah d'essayer d'ouvrir le jeu c'est
assez logique donc j'imagine que westl
va plutôt essayer de fermer soit en
faisant des 4 soit en échangeant et en
cloisonnant assez vite si possible euh
bah position vivante est intéressante en
tout cas euh après l'autre coup qu'on
pourrait tenter côté noir c'est c'est B5
en se disant ah tiens je cloue ce fou
qui peut pas partir puisque il y a la
tour derrière mais je pense Magnus vrait
simplement faire fou des deux attaquer
la dame et à ce moment-là si la dame
venait à partir on pourrait prendre et
si les Noirs font B4 bon bah ça
laisserait au blanc le l'opportunité
d'ouvrir un peu plus le jeu comme ça ou
de faire un coup comme D4 peut-être même
que j'aime bien pour pour tout échanger
et euh il commena à profiter comme je
vous disais du du manque de de de de
développement des pièces noires donc C4
joué et donc qui a bien fermé le jeu
avec
D4
alors on me demande si j'ai prévu de
publier un prochain livre et si oui sur
quel thème bah ouais on va essayer d'en
faire un autre avec Kevin euh courant
euh courant
2024 euh avec pas mal de de de
d'exercices j'ai envie de dire euh sur
différents thèmes pas que de la tactique
euh et on verra le cahier d'entraînement
a bien marché sur ce thème euh donc euh
donc fait peut-être et é lgir ça peut
être intéressant et euh et on verra
voilà là pour on en a fait deux là dans
l'année déjà donc il a le cahier
d'entraînement qui qui est sympa et le
l'Almanac
euh petit compact avec une anecdote par
jour ou un exercice par jour enfin
quelque chose à apprendre un conseil une
citation et cetera et qui est fait un
peu d'une manière différente c'est moins
des exercices même s'il y en a quand
même he disséminé tout au long du livre
mais c'est plus pour je sais pas
apprendre un peu l'histoire des éches
les grands joueurs les grands champions
du passé euh des conseils comme je vous
dis et puis le fait d'avoir chaque jour
quelque chose à faire c'est petite
routine de travail une régularité ça
fait faire sa petite démarche aux échecs
et voilà donc c'est sympathique ça peut
être aussi quelque chose qui qui s'offre
à quelqu'un d'autre plus
qu'on donc c'est un peu l'occasion VO
sortir un truc pour pour les fêtes mais
donc le prochain on n pas encore le
titre on a l'idée en tête on verra
comment ça se goupille mais mais mais
soit sortira je sais pas enfin faut
commencer à l'écrire déjà mais vers vers
juin ou septembre on va dire allez dans
cette zone de l'année
quoi en tout cas donc le jeu était fermé
par westla avec D4 Magnus islop avec K2
donc Magnus qui a donné unf qui a donné
westla a pris un pion il aller le
chercher quand même il a pas été donné
mais ça lui a coûté du développement et
Magnus j'imagine qu'avec ce k D2 qui est
prêt à bondir vers le centre de l'
chiqué et puis peut-être jouer un coup
comme B4 pour essayer d'ouvrir encore
plus la position et euh et exposer un
peu le voilà le roi adverse et et mettre
le doigt sur le manque de développement
mais mais position intéressante en tout
cas W qui qui ne refuse pas le combat
dans cette partie qui va de l'avant et
ça fait plaisir de voir ne pas baisser
les bras en tout
cas
donc les
BD2 qui pourrait peut-être retirer cette
dame alors même si pour l'instant il y a
pas un grand danger de de découverte on
voit que le foup est nulle part parce
que prendra la tour et puis il y a pas
d'échec à donner ou de grosses pièces à
attaquer mais dam C7 ce que je trouve
pas bête c'est qu'on retire quand même
la dame de vis-avis parce tôt ou tard ça
sera sûrement un problème et on donnera
l'option de jouer avec B6 et fou B7
parce que en fait on se dit que ce fou
pour l'instant il il est mal placé mais
sur cette diagonale il a peut-être son
mot à dire si on fait B6 dès maintenant
le problème c'est la dame qui n'a plus
de case de fuite alors elle en a une en
B4 mais elle sera enfermée comme ça donc
on perd la dame et donc on comprend que
si on veut jouer avec ce plan on peut
dire ah tiens je fais dame C7 et après
bah je peux faire euh B6 et je peux
faire fou B7 et je peux sortir mes
pièces en fait faut fautchir comme ça en
fait faut se dire comment j'aimerais
agancer mes pièces avec les Noirs donc
on peut imaginer de manière tiens je
joue plusieurs coups d'affilé tiens mon
fou serait pas mal mon cavalier benah je
mettrai là ou là et cetera et après dans
un deuxième temps réfléchir comment
concrètement j'y arrive et bon benah si
on voit que B6 marche pas faut arriver à
le faire marcher et donc bah Westley a
retiré d'ailleurs sa dame il a fait un
peu le coup auquel je pensais il y a eu
cahier E4 jouer et alors il a pas joué
B6 mais il a fait fou
D7 qui est quand même pas bête bah déjà
ça pourrait permettre d'échanger ce fou
au cas où et puis si est blanc refuse
l'échange alors bon je sais pas pourquoi
il vrait absolument garder ce fous hein
parce que là ça serait l' muré mais le
fou pourrait toujours revenir vers C6
donc peut-être échanger une pièce c'est
pas mal ça fait souffler
euh donc c'est
intéressant j'ai des info sur le futur
stage vers la Suisse euh bah quel genre
d'info synchrose tu voudrais en fait
j'ai je l'ai un petit peu annoncé alors
juste pas partout hein mais sur mon sur
mon Instagram je crois et sur
Linkedin mais stage je vais faire avec
Sébastien Mazé en duo sur le temps d'un
weekend donc on fait déjà ça quelques
fois ici ou là trois quatre fois par an
euh le prochain c'est fin janvier à
Paris il m'en est complet et donc ça
sera le suivant 9 et 10 mars ce sera
divon lesbains donc en France mais très
proche de la frontière Suisse entre
Genève et Lausanne voilà mais j'ai pas
plus de enfin tu peux aller consulter
les profils ou peut-être de toute façon
je l'annoncerai sur Twitter tôt ou tard
et tu pourras voir mais si tu es
intéressé ou tu peux nous écrire par
mail demande privée et après si tu en
parler autour de toi que tu connais des
gens par là-bas que ça PE intéressé bah
écoute c'est cool ça peut toujours nous
aider de faire une petite pub
quoi en tout cas Magnus qui a échangé le
fou W qui a repris du cavalier donc ça
lui développe au moins une pièce et ça
lui permet d'attaquer ce pion central en
E5 donc j'imagine que fou F4 va
suivre voilà donc W bon il est arrivé
quand à prendre ce pion comme on a dit
il y a pas de grosse attaque pour
l'instant contre lui le problème c'est
comment on va finir le développement on
VO ce roi le cavalier la tour là-bas qui
se marche un petit peu
[Musique]
dessus donc on pourrait peut-être songer
un coup comme H5 ser de mettre le
cavalier H6 puis un F5 si on arrive à
faire tout ça c'est pas mal après le
défaut de H5 évidemment çabl la C G5
donc faut voir s'il y a pas un cavalier
qui va atterrir là-bas après nous mettre
une petite pression par lui et ça
regarde là et là la dame qui pourrait
venir mais bon à voir H5 et G5 peutre 5
est possible quand même pour les
Noirs ça peut être une option l'autre
idée des blanc ça peut être de faire BK
trouver un autre front sur les chiquers
et que ça joue elroi l D et un peu
partout quoi
[Musique]
donc donc donc
chaud Nico qui dit viens en Belgique bah
écoute euh pourquoi pas tu es de quel
coin tu es de quel coin en Belgique
parce que c'est vaste après comment on
fait les stage en français il faudrait
je peux pas aller n'importe où en
Belgique non plus mais si tu connais un
coin sympa euh et qu'on puisse trouver
une salle un truc cool ben on pourrait
songer le faire une fois
hein on
verra mais mais j'aurai rien contre hein
Belgique je suis pas allé très souvent
mais c'est un pe que j'ai bien aimé les
rares fois où j'y suis allé euh donc euh
écoute si c'est possible on verra après
bon ça peut pas être tous les weekends
non plus hein mais euh mais quelques
stages dans l'année comme ça c'est cool
l'été l'été se tate avec Kef peut-être
pour en refaire un on verra euh il y a
rien de fait mais si on fait on vous
serez informé de toute façon
quoi bon en tout cas qui réfléchit mais
j'aime bien il prend sa chance dans
cette partie voilà après peut-être ça a
mal tourné il la perdra il la perdra et
puis bah ça sera fini pour ce match il
aura quand même fait un beau parcours
mais il se laisse pas perdre dans le
match comme ça sans sans bouger et comme
un agneau il a pas bien joué la partie
d'avant mais celle-là il s'est il s'est
remis dedans alors est-ce que ça sera
suffisant ça c'est dur à dire de toute
façon pour faire trébucher Magnus il en
faut mais mais il essaye il essaye il
est vaillant il a joué le petit H6
euh alors je sais pas s'il compte jouer
avec G5 ou si l'idée c'est de faire
ensuite G6 ro G7 et petit à petit
essayer de rocker à la main comme ça
euh voilà je sais pas exactement ce
qu'il cherche avec H6 en tout cas euh H4
j'allais le mentionner ça pourrait être
une manière de lutter contre un futur G5
quoi qu'il en soit et que c'est aussi
une manière d'aller mettre le pion
là-bas donc quand je tra parlais de
traitement moderne il a envoyé le pion H
a il envoit maintenant le pion h mais
ouais de mettre le pion H5 ça peut être
une idée enlever le cavalier passer la
dame et cetera et euh ouais c'est une
épine ce pion H5 hein et puis peut-être
enlever ses deux pièces après le K F3 le
fou F4 et pourquoi pas F4 F5 qui
partirait
ouvrir un peu vers le vers le roi
noir il mfrat qui attendu le stage
Luxembourg bon ça va être dur de faire
tous les pays dans l'année mais bon je
retiens les idées je retiens les idées
en tête nésitez pas en fait si des fois
écrire si vous avez des idées hein et
puis bon ben sinon vous avez le droit si
vous pouvez de bouger vous aussi de nous
rejoindre quand on en fait
ailleurs donc c'est der coup H4 al je
sais pas si Wes va changer son fusil
d'épô les faire H5 finalement pour
stopper ce pion et repartir sur le plan
C H6 k F5 ou s'il va laisser laisser ça
arriver alors peut-être il peut même
faire G6 maintenant G6 peut-être en
disant bah tiens si fait H5 je fais G5
et je garde la position fermée
euh ferm c'est vite dit he par le fou va
bouger le cavalier il aura une casse par
G4 s'il a envie il y aura F4 qui arrive
j'aime pas trop ça parce que que je vois
ça me ça me dit pas trop euh
[Musique]
ouais c'est pas simple en fait de bouger
avec cl noir c'est chiant c'est chiant
une autre idée peut-être pour sortir les
pièces c'est de faire fou des vite en se
disant tiens je sortir mon cavalier là
et puis j'aurais de deux
accès après ça faitbl un peu cette case
le C pourrait venir dessus mais qui
accomplit peut-être pas énormément
grand-chose tout de suite euh
ouais peêtre fou D8 histoire de bouger
lui remettre le fou et voir mais
bon c'est pas simple j'ai quand Mme
Magnus c'est quand même mieux mais je
retire pas ce que je disais je trouve
c'est quand Mme intéressant comme jou
quoi qu'il en soit il fait
G6 fait
G6 l'ordi n'aime
pas ça H5 comme je vous disais mais il
ouv deautre côté ave b4çon Magnus est
sur tous les front il sur tous les
chi pas mal gu totale
profite un peu hein de ces pièces
amassées là-bas là qui font rien trop
pour aller un peu ouvrir ici il tape C5
si c 5 vient disparaître ça pourrait
coûter le pion
des4 et puis ça peut avir des colonnes
très vite et donc les colonnes bah ça
favorise les tours qui côté blanc
peuvent se mobiliser contrairement à
cette tour H8 qui va mettre quand même
beaucoup de temps à venir en jeu à cause
de ce G8 qui qui la bloque hein tout
bêtement donc en tout cas eu B4 pion
prend k prend D4 euh il a tropque pion B
contre le pion D et maintenant bah
l'idée de Magnus ça d'enlever ce
cavalier de d'avancer avec le pion D3 D3
D4 D5 et peut-être prendre 6 peut-être
faire D6 donc ça c'est clairement une
idée il y a toujours ce qui peut venir
vers vers D6 la dame en F3 et ça
l'imession que ça prend forme pour les
blancs quand même c'est c'est pas simple
mais écoutez on va voir il a fait tour
D8 intéressant donc là maintenant bah
peut-être qu' B3 pour libérer le passage
au pion d peut-être qu' 6
euh dame F3 peut-être possible aussi euh
dame F3 ça serait une défense sur ce
pion de manière indirecte c'est les
Noirs venaient à prendre pour faire c
prend6 et si pion prend fou prend il y
aurait échec et on attquerit la
dame donc possible aussi bon je crois
que allez k B3 ça doit être le coup
simple on va dire euh si on veut pas
trop se prendre la tête à trop réfléchir
à des variantes après on bouge la dame
on pousse mais Magnus est parti sur dame
F3 donc c aussi un coup mentionné hein
qui semble être descent donc ça évite
qu' prend5 West qui vient de faire R7
bien joué para logique il s'est enlevé
du vis-à-vis de la
dame et je pense Magnus va aller en G3
avec sa dame pour couvrir ce pion et se
positionner face au roi et zoner
peut-être un H5 à un moment donc donc on
va
voir
D6
ouais il s'infil fou prend il élimine
puion on prend mais on voit que les
cases noir c'est un peu problématique
quand même pour pour
Wesley il a plus le fou et il a ses
pions sur case blanche donc ça peut être
un souci mais pour l'instant ce qu' des
qui quand même arrive un peu à contrôler
les cases là que j'ai mis en
rouge qui allez qui se bat qui fait le
taf LEB comment ça se passe ça se passe
que ça suit pour Wesley mais
euh de la force au chat mais il essaye
hein je encourager les chats leur dire
les boîtes les boîtes ne sont peut-être
pas perdu sont pas encore
perdus non mais je trouvais qu'il avait
raison de jouer comme il fait après bon
ilyper hper et puis voilà mais il essaye
au moins il prend des quelques petits
risques voilà
ouais après il pourrait gagner toujours
deux fois d'affilé sur demande
c'est une grosse demande mais oui oui
mais bon kiakin l'avait fait je crois
contre
Zidler plus la Coupe du monde 2015 là
mais c'est pas mort encore cette partie
c'est pas fini encore non non non c'est
loin d'être mort mais oui bon c'est pas
facile quoi enfin mais il y a pas de G
direct il y a pu se passer plein de
choses hein on voit souvent de toute
façon les parties fin avec peu de temps
de part et d'autre donc en fin de partie
tu oubli un truc tuas les pion passer
dame qui te déboule dessus et puis voilà
enfin ça peut arriver
quoi qualité de l'air est mauvaise tu en
a parlé j'imagine déjà ouais alors elle
était bonne au début de la partie alors
c'était pas le cas de de l'humidité de
la température ça la cata depuis le
début du tournoi mais la qualité de
l'air ils avaient dû peut-être aérer
rapidement
mais
Magnus qui réfléchit sa que là c'est
quasiment une balle de
matchti je sais pas quoi BVC qui demande
c'est une grosse compè en France prévu
bientôt et cetera bah non c'est dommage
il y avait la BUP la semaine dernière il
y a une semaine tout juste
d'ailleurs une belle compète où tu avais
tu avais des beaux
joueurs faudra attend la 4e on sait pas
trop quand si elle aura lieu mais euh
voilà sinon en France c'est longtemps
qu'il y a plus de grossse compétition en
fait c'était le Grand chestour Paris le
dernier truc un peu euh un peu
prestigieux ouais euh tu as des Open ou
tu as des bons joueurs mais tu as pas
les top joueurs mondiaux du tout euh
peut-être tu peux venir au championnat
de France des clubs au Top 16 tu peux
croiser quelques beaux joueurs peut-être
Maxime quelques parties hein il joue pas
tout mais mais c'est pas pr pré non
ouais non tu as pas de grand grand
tournois en France malheureusement il y
a eu pendant longtemps et puis il y a eu
les trophées imopard il y a eu y eu
beaucoup de choses en France et puis
petit à petit ça a disparu non il faut
que tu voyages euh écoute tu peux avir
les candidat cette année si tu veux
aller au Canada là tu auras des beaux
joueurs mais non mais disons en Europe
euh tu vas avir le grand chest tour à
Zagreb tuas Zagreb et varsov Bucharest
et Bucharest Bucharest aussi ouais
Varsovie Zagreb Bucharest allez c'est
c'est trois destinations où tu peux
vraiment croiser des des des stars
euh n'y a même plus de grand grands Open
en Europe he alors il y a un peu cjess
mais c'est pas non plus ouais non non en
fait si c'est pas très bien enfin c'est
Dan c'est tu as beaucoup de joueurs
de600
mais tuas alexenko numéro 2 en fait tu
vois c'est
pas un peu la BND je suis en train de
regarder hein si vous voyez regarder le
téléphone parce que je suis en train de
jeter un œil Bundesliga si tu tombes sur
des beaux matchs peut-être tu peux ouais
tu peux peut-être viser un weekend de
Bundesliga où ça peut être pas si
mal il a pas l'air bien
lenèou Pranav
mais dangereux Pranav ouais je crois que
c'est un pote à Carlsen non il jou dans
son équipe norvégienne la Coupe d'Europe
des Clubs il me
semble
h bon enlevé sa dame bon Magnus qui
réfléchi peut-être que s'il réfléchit
trop on pour avir un espoir avec la
pendule mais position prometteuse en
tout cas
euh quand Mme un pion de plus pour
Wesley exactement il table
là-dessus mais peut-être ouais H5 on
provoque G5 on enlève le fou on enlève
la dame on fait F4 on ouvre tout quoi
paraî logique C
enchaînement en tout cas il tankque près
fois est-ce que E5 peut être une menace
pour les
Noirs probablement probablement on dit
Gibraltar Gibraltar c'est mort mais ça
existe plus Gibraltar en fait c'était
ouais c'était bien chaque année j'aimais
bien moi j'allais le jouer souvent mais
ils ont démoli l'hôtel où ça avait lieu
là l'hôtel Caléta ah ils veulent le
reconstruire mais bon ça se pr de jours
quoi donc tu aura peut-être un Gibraltar
quiaura lieu et il y a le tata style
aussi auquel on n pas pensé tata style
ouais ouais mais c'est en janvier après
le problème c'est que je crois que la
ville et le climat sont pas terribles
donc tu vas vraiment pour regarder des
échecs mais bon si c'est le but de ta
démarche à ce moment-là bah très bien et
oui tu auras un beau plateau tu peux
aller au TA style donc c'est vaanzi
c'est en Hollande au mois de janvier là
euh pourquoi
pas mais bon en tout cas en France non
quoi
voilà désolé de te le
dire on est très dég fait tour alors s
re une gaffe les chats y
croient alors gaffe je sais pas c'est
vrai que ça pas logique mais l'ordi
n'aime pas en tout cas bah ça va enfin
permettre à de développer ce qui G8
voilà c'est choses faites qui dormait
depuis depuis longtemps là-bas et qui
enfin peut participer au jeu Magnus qui
est parti avec son cavalier qui doit
vouloir per C5 D4 c5our C1 et avancer
petit à petit est-ce que tu penses que
ça Ronon chez Wesley ça y croit un petit
peu Moler
peut-êtrere tour H8 mettre cette tour en
jeu un
peu
ça reste pas évident à jouer pour les n
j'imagine mais il se bat c'est pas
perdant voilà il se place allez c'est
joué il garde garde qu une petite minute
d'avance ch des coup de Griff quand il
voit ce point d'interrogation là à
l'écraness chasser de
faireogation
inéresse pas du tout à mon
avis parti qui ça va s'emballer la FAB
bah toujours quand il y a moins de temps
à la fin Magnus qui trouve pas ce qu'il
veut je trouve un peu lent
ouais après bon quand il accélère il il
nous a pas fait de grosse gaffe Magnus
encore ah j'imine tu jou pas le coup num
de l'ordi C5 à cause de E5 quand même
qui est un peu relou donc tu as
peut-être envie de jouer D4 plutôt mais
il y a dame prend C4 fou C fa fou C
ouais dure 5 on ferme tout çain
ouais carrément il se prend une croix je
pense chass ch roné ils mettent ça ouais
les petites oreilles quoi ok il joue 5
assez vite peut-être tour 6 maintenant
je sais pas un coup comme ça pour on se
place pourrait même la gagner ah bah oui
il peut hein mais bon j'imagine toujours
pas mieux objectivement mais mais bon on
peut toujours y
croire une question pourquoi Westley le
chat euh Wesley le chat bah en fait il a
des chats chez lui déjà et euh et c'est
son sa photo sur chesscom sur son profil
c'est un chat quoi un de ses chats donc
voilà ou il les partage sur Twitter et
puis il a dit que sil gagne le tournoi
il offrirait une boî de thon au chat BO
de ton au chat je sais pas il parle tout
le temps de ses chats quoi du coup du
coup voilà
chat
quoi mais là je me dis qu'il va même la
gagner hein peut-être c'est pas mal B6
ça permet de de faire à 5 ça prend les
cases au cavalier ça renforce tout et
puis peut-être à tout Russ tu reprend D6
on va voir Magnus qui est un peu plus
inconfortable tout d'un coup il suit un
peu
non alle on ESP il fait G4 il tente il
tente son vatou
ah encore un point
d'interrogation pour le coup je trouve
pas ça si mal J jou hein mais ouais mais
bon il les enchaîne il est il est à
contresens et il a perdu beaucoup de
temps pour jouer beaucoup de mauvais
coups
Mo j'ai vite de jouer par W là il s'en
va il ve pas avir F de en face c'est
très bien
joué Magnus qui a complètement implosé
mais je pense qu'il a besoin de jouer A5
il aura tout bien consolidé après il
pourra pourra soit faire tour 6 soit k
C5 soit je ne sais quoi alors k D2 où
est-ce qu'il va il peut-être G5 puis
cavalier4 c'est logique ce cavalier en
B3 tu l'avais dit il était complètement
enferré là dans ses
pions et donc il t de trouver notre
direction t jouer vient attaquer ce pion
D6 c'est pas mal
G5 est-ce qu'on prend H5 ou cavalier E8
pour attaquer
D6
partirais plutôt en H5
moi
aussi tu viens quand même vers F4 c'est
exactement
ça mais est-ce qu'on va y arriver estce
que on laisse pas un cavalier venir en
E4 nous embêter et puis peut-être un D3
D4 nous enlever le SOC le 5 et se
retrouve avec un Caval H5 finalement
plutôt en jeu l'ordinateur lui va E8
directement il se laisse prendre h6 il
s'en fout al h prang j'imagine h pr va
arriver on va voir où va Westley s'il va
H5 non il va en H7 alors 3ème solution
que qu'on avait pas envisagé mais qui
n'est pas trop apprécié de l'ordier un
nouveau je pense ça appelle cavalier E4
hein 4 je pense qu'il ve C cavalier C5
ouais
euh et quoi dame G3 il le défend D3 ok
bon peut-être qu'il faut prendre ce D6
un jour hein peutêtre bien joué parce
que du cou C5 si enfin il tape E5 et T
prend D6 peut-être qu'il vient E4 à ce
moment-là il a pris des 6 le va venir en
4 fait des peut-être t reprend on s'en
fout quoi donne la qualité
et on s'installe avec nos cavaliers on
tient un peu tout et on pousse nos pions
de partout
non c'est ce que tu veux c'est ce que
l'ordi veut c'est ce que tout le monde
veut allez wle mais bon c'est une chose
de le faire à l'entraînement c'est une
autre de le jouer en partie ça Fab
exactement
ser plus Magnus qui le jouerait ça et il
le fait allez Westley j'espère que c'est
fort moi je sais pas mais ça m'a l'air
cohérent soit d F8 on tient tout soit k
C5 peut-être et on avance si on peut là
on a quand même déjà trois pions pour la
qualité c'est beau on va faire a 5 on va
tout consolider on a nos pions passés
liés là-bas l'eld
dames TR que c'est loin d'être clair non
mais c'est lo d'être clair ça on est
d'accord l'ORD dit juste complètement
gagnant après dame C5 c'est double Atta
dam il a mis le cavalieré dommage
Westley pe dame F5 quand même pour venir
tenir des cases parce
que est-ce que dame 5 pourra arriver
euh on va
voir ça a l'air logique
mets-toi pas trop mal au temps
ouis c'est très pleutre bon après s'il
tient toute sa position
que les pion
avancer 4 pour F4 je dire fait tu
défends un
truc il avance on
vo4 c'est gagant
pas é
Compagnie F se
coup j'ai mais bon allez les
chats parce que dame F5 ouais bon d F5
façon je fais qu' F3
et en
fait 26 secondes c'est une partie
important la FAB ça pourrait être le
coup de glas pour
Wesley surtout que ça peut tomber dans
un sens ou dans l'autre ça peut faire 11
ou 2-0 enfin g 1 tu es complètement là
évidemment 20 tu es plus là du0 tu es
plus là du tout donc c'est une partie
qui C cher trou 5 tour 5 tour 5 tempo en
plus il fait mal c'est pas mal joué he
Mar c'est le coup numéro 1 mais ça aussi
c'est le coup numéro 1 les tourchin ils
veulent quoi en fait tous il veut
pousser F5 peut-être il veut pousser F5
ouais et mon tour D5 bien joué alle un
coup de
griffe il enchaîne la première
ligne peêtre B7 tuit légèrement plus
logique pour que c tour on verra en ou
plus logique mais là il y a plus de
logique Fab fa jouer des coups faut
juste c pr
pr c'est ce que je pensais aussi il est
ven
échangerent faire des fourchettess F4
c'est pas
mal Bou mais
attends mais attends il
encoreom encore LEB c'est
gag qu'il a joué on sa pas qu'il jou
pense non attends il
il ça Gagné a tout gagné je sais pas
il mais c'est encore
gagnant Pousse Pousse Pousse c'est là
qu'il a tué
pousse en fait il menace rien
pousse je crois que ça va bouge ton ro
je crois qu'il va gagner bouge ton roi
bouge le encore peêre en 7
pour je crois que ça va je cro ça va il
va répéter une fois il va réfléchir un
petit peu ah non ouais attends il il va
faire il Vaour ah non il va faire tour
des7 il tour
des per non mais cavalier F4 encore et
cavalier
H5 allez chat prends fourchette quoi
ah
F4 qui H5 quelle chance
quoi bon bien joué Wesley il nous
relance ce
match belle partie disputter hein
attends ça incroyablement explosé à quel
moment
ici là il y a que des croix juste qu'
prend H7 ou
bon F4 je crois juste ah faut
trouver c'est sûr quoi je pensais que
cétait ro F1 juste il fr 4 éche non mais
F3
bravo merde pr une photo de cette
position poures
souvenirs et ben écoute westle qui est
revenu un partout qui a bien joué dans
cette partie bon bien sûr il est passé
très proche du précipice mais il a pris
la ce qu'il fallait et c'est animé
euh bah c'était bien mieux que la
première pour lui on va voir comment il
se débrouille refaire une petite pause
peut-être
et je jejà mettre en place pour la
prochaine
partie mets le score on inverse les de
trucs
jeais bien mis onetrouve tout à l' tout
suite tout de
suite your performance change the game
with air things a new opening for your
wall is here capture new major pieces on
unique metal posters from displate now
with the official collection from
Chess.com Mount them in seconds with a
tool free magnet kit and swap them
whenever you like make your move get an
exclusive discount on all metal posters
shop now with the code chess
displate.com
[Musique]
he
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez on est de retour et ça vient de
repartir W avec les pièces blanches qui
a changé de premier coup qui a joué D4
euh peut-être mécontent d'avoir perdu
hier avec le coup E4 aujourd'hui avec le
coup B3 et donc il cherche à changer un
petit peu et donc il tente le coup D4 au
premier coup donc bon c'est un Wesley
capable de jouer toutes les
ouvertures il serait peut-être pas
mécontent une partie un petit peu plus
calme pour calmer les esprits avant de
repartir la partie avant était très très
très animée et donc donc on va voir on
verra donc c'est une Nimzo indienne
choisie par par Magnus ouverture bien
sûr très joué à haut
niveau avec Dame C2 donc qui évite les
pions doublés chez les
Blancs voilà ouverture solide
quoi parmi les ouvertures
solides donc dame prend C3 qui qu Atta
la dame il est reparti se cacher en C2
et C5 pour lutter pour le
centre il vient de prendre jou alors
tout ça toujours théorique bien sûr
euh cavalier F3 joué défend la case D4
sur laquelle le cavalier aurait pu
arriver et également bah développe
simplement le cavalier donc c'est pas
mal dame à 5 échec alors ona bien jouer
B4 mais malheureusement ce coup n'est
pas possible si cavalier prend on a un
clouage à régler donc il a dû faire fou
des de dame prend C5 et E3 B TR il
fallait parce qu'il y avait menace de
mat là-bas ça échange j'ai l'imession
que est vraiment pas contre une petite
nul dans celle-là il il s'est vraiment
fait violence dans la partie précédente
pour essayer d'aller chercher la
victoire et il est all la chercher en
prenant des
risques mais là euh il choisit vraiment
un truc très très solide très symétrique
pas de risque pas de risque chez hosley
ça va il a perdu le N son quotat de
partie blanche ça suffit il a dit stop
maintenant je je ne perdrai pas cette
partie en gros c'est ça qui en train de
dire donc petit rock des Noirs bon je
m'attends à ce que les Blancs puissent
aussi rocker alors peut-être il va
entamer par B4 avant cher cette dame il
fait tour C1 pourquoi pas il place la
tour sur une colonne ouverte il protège
sa dame c'est un coup pas mauvais euh
ouais il a peut-être un léger léger
léger avantage avec les blancs mais
c'est microscopique j'ai envie de dire
et probablement ça se dirige vers une
petite nulle tout ça euh pas de gros
combat et de partie folle comme la
précédente a priori pour cette partie
mais c'est un match hein c'est pas que
une partie puis une partie ça s'enchaîne
il y a une dynamique et et et peut-être
wesle sentait le besoin de souffler
euh pourquoi pas je je peux pas dire
soit mal mal ou bien faudra attendre la
fin du match pour pour pouvoir en parler
et dire sil raison de le faire ou pas il
aurait pu tenter aussi de se dire allez
peut-être que c'est le moment de Tom
c'est le moment où je dois lui faire mal
peut-être qu'il doute un peu après la
dernière partie et et aller mais mais
bon comme je dis dur à
dire donc toujours toujours plus facile
après
coup tour de8 jouer en tout cas en
face et euh alors je sais pas si Wesley
va jouer B4 chasser cette dam tu va
simplement rocker il y a pas de problème
pour Rock il a
rocker et les noir bah comme souvent
dans ces c'est pas un grand bidam mais
dans C ouvertures de P d'AM ils doivent
gérer le problème de leur fout casse
blanche et après ils ont plus aucun
problème
euh donc pour se faire bah souvent on
essaie de mettre le fou sur cette
diagonale ou faire5 ou une trisème
optionarrive à faire fou des7 fou E8
pour libérer la CE pour la tour en E8 le
fou n'est pas hyper actif mais en tout
cas il gêne plus aucune pièce et tout le
monde tout monde peut bien se placer
donc c'est l'option qu'il a choisi B4
jouer la dame va probablement aller se
réfugier en E7 en gros je pense le setup
des Nord cette dame E7 fou E8 tour C8
tout bien et euh et pas de faiblesse et
très solide et normalement il y a pas
d'histoire quand c'est comme
ça dame B2 de Westley donc il évacue
cette colonne C parce en prévision de
l'arrivée de la tour adverse ici fou
vite jouer bon mais tout est très
logique hein du
coup pas grand chose à ajouter hein ça
joue manière très correcte très solide
de part et
d'autre et oui Boogie du 30 il y a un
partout il y a un partout Magnus a gagné
la première partie Westley a égalisé de
manière un peu héroïque à la partie
précédente et on est la troisème partie
je rappelle c'est un match en quatre
parties donc s'il y a un vainqueur au
bout des quatre parties bah très bien et
si jamais il y a deux partout il faut
une 5ème ultime partie euh cadence
Armagedon c'està-dire cadence à laquelle
les blanc ont plus de temps mais sont
obligés de gagner euh mais bon on n est
pas là il y a déjà les quatre premières
parties à jouer hier Magnus avit gagné
la première manche de points et demi à
un point et demi à l'issue des quatre
parties donc il mène un set à 0 et là on
est donc dans le 2uxè set de cette
grande finale du champion cheest tour
euh et donc c'est la troisème partie de
cette de ce deuxème set voilà même si le
format peut sembler un peu compliqué
quand ça prière fois vous voyez on s'y
fait petit à petit
euh et et donc voilà c'est la troisème
partie pour l'instant très serré les
joueurs ont d'ailleurs pas mal de temps
encore à disposition plus de 13 minutes
pour Wesley plus de 12 pour Magnus
et j'imagine mal une décision se faire
dans cette partie c'est vraiment très
très très symétrique plus tellement de
pièces sur les chqu bientôt parce que là
bon il y a que un cavalien fou qui s
échangé de chaque côté mais on peut
facilement imaginer disparition des
tours étant donné que les quatre tours
sont sur les colonnes ouvertes et donc
on peut avoir un jeu d'échange qui se
met en place très très
prochainement si Magnus n'ait pas gagné
hier si si Magnus a gagné hier le le
premier set là c'est le deuxème set je
sais pas comment expliquer différemment
je viens de le faire mais mais voilà au
donc c'est les deux mêm joueurs qui se
raffrontent sur 2 7 voire 3 s'il y a un
7 partout donc il y a un 70 pour magn et
un partout dans le deè
set demande si Magnus a gaffé la
dernière bah un peu ouais mais c'était
une partie compliqué peu de
temps évidemment il aurait pu gagner
mais mais c'était chaud c'était chaud
et je trouvais que c'était plutôt bien
tenté de la part de Westley de jouer une
partie comme ça de toute façon dos au
mur puisqu'il avait perdu la première
partie et donc il fallait essayer
quelque
chose
Magnus qui réfléchit
ici probablement plusieurs bonnes
options s'offre à
lui pour pour simplifier un peu tout ce
qui se passe là long de ses colonnes
sans
Wesley regardez un peu à côté tranquille
H6 joué par Magnus bon un petit coup de
temporisation pourquoi
Pasin qui renforce plus ou moins sa
position si on veut ça a des histoires
de mat du couloir peut-être un jour et
euh je pense qu'il attend que Westley
bouge ce cavalier pour initier un petit
peu les échanges éventuellement le long
de la colonne
D wley qui copie wley qui copie Magnus
qui fait
H3 petit CP cou un peu un peu à l'instar
du H6 joué précédemment par par Magnus
ouais partie pas méga passionnantein
désolé on est dépendant de du choix des
joueurs et euh et donc dans cette Nimzo
indienne très symétrique très solide on
n pas le spectacle qu'on pouvait espérer
ouais je regardais un petit ça de loin
Fab mais ouais mais ouais ça a peut-être
eu raison hein s cassé les dents déjà
deux fois avec les Blancs exactement
mais j'aiécouté un peu son
interview réalisé par la présentatrice
norvégienne
euh qui demandait alors comment tu
penses pouvoir peut-être gagner cette
manche r un partout
wesle est en PS peut-être peut-être à
l'armagedon donc on sentait que il
cétait pas là d'après ce qu'il disait
qu'il comptait faire vraiment la
différence après bien sûr toujours
prendre avec des pincettes tous ces
interviews ça ve pas forcément dire
grand-chose
hein mais disons
euh j'ai pu interpréter ça comme allez
de nuls ça me dérange pas quoi
après on l'a bien vu dans ce match hein
les Noirs ont quasiment autant de chance
de gagner les blancs qui pourra se
mettre en contre à la prochaine
ouais
fin F3 ça peut-être que les tours vont
disparaître dans les les TR qu prochains
coups déjà une de
moins vers la nul mais ça peut genre de
parties qui peuvent quand même durer
surtout que je sais pas quelle est leur
règle concernant les propositions de nul
j'ai cru voir dans les petites
vidéos des fois sur Twitter ou quoi
qu'ils ont un petit écran qui o tu as le
nom du coup enfin là ça serait écrit euh
22 point b3d1 quoi euh donc peut-être
qu'ils peuvent pas faire nul avant le
20e le 30e le 40e ou pas du tout hein
qui font nul quand ils veulent mais que
on juste il ils proposent pas je sais
pas aès ils ont peut-être été un peu
briefés aussi là-dessus parce que si tu
te rappelles au début de ces
championnats champion ch tour il y avait
des nuls en 5 coups c'était ah c'est
vrai que c'est pas super bon spectacle
mais bon après c'est des compétiteurs
ils ont leur match à gérer et
peut-être des petits briefings là les
mecs quand même faut pas ils ont le
droit ils ont le droit mais oui c'est
mieux pour le public ou alors bon met
une règle il y a pas de faire nul en
moins de temp temps de coup on le
définit et
voilà quand même il y a un grand jeu
quoi c'est quand même un titre majeur de
la
saison et ouais 100k de différence c'est
que le perdant gagnera 100k et le
vainqueur 200 K donc euh voilà c'est
quand même une énorme différence donc
euh on peut comprendre c'est les gens
ont besoins de souffler qui doivent
faire nul près tant d'émotion avant et
une semaine acharnée de compétition déjà
à Toronto après ils sont des joueurs qui
sont quand même déjà richissime hein euh
donc 100000 c'est pas non plus le même
impact pour euh que pour un un lambda
comme moi quoi ouais bah par
exemple mais euh mais ça reste quand
même une somme quoi qu'il en
soit pour toi 200 €
je veux bien aussi oui voilà c'est ça
tuas quand même
jouerre pour les gens le chat par la
somme de 5 € 10
€ ça reste quand même une
somme il a pas complètement abandonné FA
ah pas du tout que soit le match et la
position bon la position je pense pas
qu'il ait trop d'ambition mais mais il
est capable de contrer
ça prend trop de risque en face mais
Magnus n'a pas l'air de d'en prendre
spécialement he c'est pour l'instant
c'est très très calme al il fait Tor C4
est-ce qu'il a l'intention peut-être
d'aller transférer la T vers G4
simplement
doubler doubler ça ça paraît normal hein
mais peut-être un coup comme quiivé E7
propose vraiment un échange et puis si
tu vas vers G4 attisqu péril parce que
bon CER tu men mat mais on va arriver à
défendre quand même G6 F5 je ne sais
quoi H5 après pour chasser et puis tu
nous laisses la colonne
C en tout cas les les chat pe être
content de leur
esclave qui va se battre pour pour en
tout
cas nombre de
de marche par
paire
même 5 € on prend tu vois dans le chat B
tout à fait on prend
tout dévergondé bien reconnu les 10plate
dans notre dos
ah dis plate partenaire du
tournoi histoire de 5 € ça me faisait
penser la
modique la chanson du
dimanche donnez
donnez-moiatmoi le pouvoir d'achat
donnez donnez-moi le pouvoir
d'acheter du lcht il y va avec T T4 il
va puis
j'épargnerai 1000 € à l'excellent tau de
4 % ce qui me fera au bout de 10 ans la
coquette somme de 400 € 400 € c'est
beaucoup d'argent ouais très belle
chanson je
pourrais l'ospice de bébé donnez
donnez-moi le pouvoir
d'achat dommage qu'il arrêté chanson
dimanche la pêche 3
4 il on fait pas mal hein de de chansons
sympa tu passes t temps le jour la nuit
devant l'écran tu n besoin de personne
sonne
son bon du coup il se passe des choses
finalement cette partie B qu'on chante
ça ça ça animé heureusement en fait he
sans ça je crois que d bleu maintenant
tuas les d
bleu les gens qui connaissent ou
sûrement mais non personne commande trop
il y avait aussi la chanson des cheminau
ouaisou
cheminauentends-tu il suit les cheminau
parce que c'est la grve quoi les Anglais
qui sont là
et alors cette finale meilleure
structure blanche mais bon la tour noir
rentré et euh le Lou est peut-être dans
la bergerie attention
c'est partie
qui finalement euh ouais mais il se
passe des
choses l'air de rien je t'en prie je
t'en
prie c'est j'ai une question
intéressante comment expliquer le taux
élevé de ppm ce soir je sais pas je sais
pas
c'est ils sont pas vraiment arrivés à
régler ce souci effectivement on sent
que c'est pas des conditions idéales
pour les joueurs qui pourtant nous
sortent de belles
parties exactement la bonne
humeur
meurmur quelquesuns quand même qui
connaissent cette chanson du dimanche
qui ça déjà un petit moment hein c'est
ça ne rajunit pas tout ça
mais c'était sympathique donc G5 joué
par Magnus bah G5 il met sa structure en
place le pion é attaqué donc du coup il
est défendu et puis maintenant le fou
pourrait peut-être naviguer de ce côté
donc est-ce que West peut-être ramener
la tour en C4 pour venir couvrir ou
est-ce qu'il va tenter d'aller contrer
de ce côté mais on risque de voir la
Tour Noire attaquer à 3 par ici ou par
là ou la seconde
rangée donc on va
voir
ch juste les clés de chez moi ah alors
je te ne les ai pas prises pas dans ce
coin
là bon je crois pas mais
vérifion je repasse allez à
toute et donc W qui a bien joué tour C4
pour bien échanger t prend cavalier
prend cette finale avec le cavalier face
au
fou souvent des finales intéressantes
parce que c'est rapport asymétrique de
pièces à peu près de même valeur dans
l'absolu
mais intéressant on pourrait penser à un
plan pour les blanc de monter ce pion 5
qui pourrait permettre au cavalier
d'atterrir en D6 peut-être sur case
noire où le fou ne pourrait
pas le
chasser Wesley qui monte son G3 7 est-ce
que les CHS il croi les chats ils y croi
pas trop mais ils sont pas mécontents
ils sont
faire433 roi des 4 je pense que W il
peut jouer un truc sans qu'il est très
heureux que ro3 j'avais peur de fou C6
en fait qui nous réexpé làbas on aura pu
faire 4 et partir il fait
F4 il en a gagné une très belle il y a
pas longtemps contre un certain Lévon
Aronian de finale en Pary lante une très
très belle finale que je te recommande
tu pourrais te délecter à la faire en
cours à la singfield ouais une très très
bon finale pour le coup ok tu peux t'en
délecter à mon avis c'est non mais Ben
très bien 50 coups de roit fou contre
tris cavaliers c'est vraiment super bien
joué mais tu délectes à analyser ça tu
peux te délecter Fab je vais la noter
sur mon téléphone être noté mes élèves
vont se régaler ah ils vont se délecter
je crois qu'on peut le dire c'est so
Aronian SIG fi Cup
2023 si tu veux te casser la tête avec
une finale roi fou TR cavalier c'est
l'idéal finale très très complexe Fabien
tu NIS pas fait sur la chaîne alors oh
que non oh que non on a évité le
trackenard trnar évité d's on sait pas
quelle partie on fera encore pour le
moment ce match on feraon une sûrement
que oui sûement parce qu'on est quand
même obligé on fait quand même de
l'actualité là le vainqueur du champion
chestour Fabien comment peux-tu même
imaginer faire l'impasse sur cette
compétition non non non j'imagine B
mais mais tu l'imaginais quand même mais
non mais comme demain matin j'ai un
train que ce soir on sait pas comment
les choses se passent tuis je me dis ah
peut-être je vais manquer ça quoi pas de
chance pour moi
ça serait vraiment
dommage mais un train ça se loupe ça se
loupe surtout pour pour analyser cette
finale
peut-être un petit coup comme E4
peut-être pour barrer la route du roi
noir sur on pourraitre-re par ah E5 je
va faire roi F5 et te délecté de cette
case G6
qu' forca peut-être le fou all ver8 mais
bon k C4
hop i genre qui est mieux non B
peut-être égal quoi sur cavalier 4 tu
fais quoi bon je serai ver des5 tu veux
me faire c
c345556 à3 B5 peut-être 3 B4 3 Bou je
reprends B5 4 à 5 ah c'est en B5 c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle c'est pour ça
donc il a jouer roi
C6 moi j'ai l'impression que ce sont les
blancs qui pressent un petit peu
bah le Roi peut être un poil plus actif
effectivement attention au fou quie 5
est sur case aussi
noir et donc la ch dimanche il y a des
gens qui ça va il y avait il av certains
connaisseurs après oui bon j'imagine que
les plus jeunes doivent pas trop avoir
la ref c'était tellement bien ce truc
marrant il y a tellement de trucs bien
qui disparaissent ouais
terrible puis de la merde qui apparaî
quoi enfin ça c'est la du dimanche pour
le coup c'était vraiment cool ouais
alors des fois il a des trucs bien qui
apparaissent aussi attention hein mais
euh bon pas toujours hein non surtout
que là c'était vraiment cool pour le
coup j' arri à
Paris ça je prends le TR c'est pas
pour aujourd'hui c'est la grve c'est
quoi la
GR
c'estop je prends le taxi
pas va
plus génial
[Musique]
c'est une sorte de petite satire sociale
gentillette
drôle très drôle surtout surtout drôle
il av fait une petite série après je
crois ch du mat
série moins bien que les chansons mais
qui P se regarder à 6 he
perdu
ah les chansons étaient belles h
le rythme la bonne humeur la pêche cé
toujours
ouais la petite pointe d'humour à chaque
fois don finalement Magnus qui avait à
réactiver ce roin vers le centre
et
euh il va pas rentrer nulle part mais je
te la je reviens dans une vingtaine de
minutes allez à tout de suite
à tout de
suite tu pourras te délecter de la 4e
partie de ce match je pense à ton
retour ah oui si Armagedon évidemment ça
j'entends bien que tu comptes pas le
rater on en est plus très loin on en est
plus très loin les amis d'un potentiel
Armagedon quand même qui nous ferait
très plaisir pas queon pour avoir unè
bien évidment il y a un autre Armagedon
ensuite à tout de
suite
bon ça manœuvre normalement comme je dis
ça do se finire par la nul parce que
parce que il y a barricade ce qui C3
qu'est-ce qu'il fait défend la case de 4
le pion tac tac il met les Barbel
celui-là il met ASI un Barb celui-là il
est Barbel hop hop hop en fait il y a du
rouge partout donc comment le roi noir
pourrait-il rentrer quand Mme il
viendrait par là de toute façon on va
changer de couleur là on donner un
trajet potentiel possible bah tu vas
là-bas c'est bien mais et après donc
normalement les Blancs ont bien tout
défendu et peuvent juste attendre
tranquillement avec des coups de roi att
de pas bouger le CAL bien sûr qu'
laisserait la place au roi noir mais là
comme ça ça va c'est très
solide et je m'attends à une petite
répétition en fait je dois dire
euh mais on verra fou C6 jouer ro F2
voilà de toute façon les blancs peuvent
pas faire
grand-chose ils attendent ils attendent
je pense pas que Magnus de et de passage
malgré tout sa classe en
finale ne devrait pas suffire ro F52 il
peut aller jusqu'en G4 avec son bien sûr
on l'avait signalé mais le roi
reviendrait en F2 pour tout
défendre c'est tenté d'ailleurs de la
part du norvégien mais Westley vigilant
revient les ro repartent c'est en train
de répéter les coups et c'est une petite
nulle petite nulle donc dans dans C
parti
euh B du coup
écoutez on en est là un point et demi
partout
euh et ben c'est c'est pas mal
euh je vais partir en petite pause je
gettete pour la 4e partie et je vous dis
à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on est de retour les j les joueurs
viennent de
s'installer à la table de
jeu
et c'est parti Magnus qui entame par D4
cette
partie il avait pas encore joué ça je
crois dans leur face à face on
verra enin dans face à face aujourd'hui
je veux dire D4 Cali F6 c46 et donc
cavalier F3 il a pas laissé la nimso
indienne sur quoi westle jouer D5 c'est
la variante semitarche vante moderne où
les blancs jouentve Cali G5 fou6 pour
défendre c pr 6 probablement puis on
prend le
6 petit défaut de structure pour les
Noirs mais en général c'est quand même
une vente très très très solide réputé
vraiment blindé une sorte de berlinoise
contre des4 on va dire entre entre
guillemets et que Westley maîtrise
bien
désolé mais Magnus bon voilà peut
essayer dans cette dans cette variante
c'est une finale on sait que c'est un
bon joueur
technique et donc il peut tenter sa
chance comme cela euh W donc qui
réfléchit donc après ce coup fou des
deux euh on a on a plus l'habitude de
voir k pr peut-être jouer à ce stade là
mais c'est un coup qui qu' pourra
peut-être jouer ultérieurement donc
j'imagine peut-être Wesley développer ce
fou pour ensuite mettre le roin E7 se
cacher parce que sur ro D8 bien sûr
peutêre vulnérable au long de la de la
colonne D donc on on ver ce qu'il peut
jouer et on me demande c'est l'armagéon
et non pas encore ce n'est que la 4e
partie du match euh 4e partie du match
euh il y a un point et demi partout les
joueurs donc sont dosado à égalité et ça
peut être une partie décisive en cas de
de victoire Magnus Carlsen il sera le
grand vainqueur de ce champion ch tour
2023 euh là son c'est vraiment la la
finale qui a marqué ENF disons du
circuit qui qui qui a marqué toute
l'année il y a eu six tournois
qualificatifs
auparavant et d'ailleurs Magnus a été
disons le joueur le
plus le plus en forme en tout cas qui a
le mieux réussi dans ces tournois tout
au long de l'année euh où donc il y
avait les huit premiers au classement
général qui se qualifiaient pour pour ce
tableau final qui était donc réuni à
Toronto on avait deux représentants
français on avait Maxime ch la grave on
avait alira firouja euh il y avait aussi
donc bah Magnus Carlsen West leso ikarou
Nakamura qui faisait figure peut-être
d'épouvantaille aux yeux de certains
Fabiano carwana aussi était là
euh la surprise laavic qui est arrivé à
se qualifier au nez à la barbe de
joueurs comme
nepomniashi ou ou Guiri disons des
joueurs plus plus connu du grand public
et et donc ces huit joueurs avaient déjà
commencé le tournoi donc samedi dernier
avec un tournoi de qualification jouont
tous les uns contre les autres euh et
euh et donc au bout duquel il fallait se
qualifier pour les
demi-finales et donc en demi-finale on a
retrouvé Magnus Carlsen West lo Fabiano
carwana et Nadi back abdous satorov le
jeune joueur Bek qui avait été champion
du monde rapide en
2021 et euh et Magnus est opposé à son
éternel rival j'ai envie de dire Fabiano
carwana mais on sait qu'en rapide quand
même Magnus prévut en général et cette
fois encore il s'est imposé au bout de
deux armesageddon Magnus éit donc
qualifié pour pour la finale et West
leso a eu plus de mal he contre
noierbeck il avait dû passer par la
troisème manche euh mais il était arrivé
à se dépétrer du Tenas joueur ousbek
pour donc se qualifier pour cette grande
finale qui a commencé hier et donc
Magnus av remporté le premer set et là
donc on voit le deuxème M7 maintenant
donc toujours est-il que Magnus dans
cette partie n'est pas venu prendre ce
fou qui aurait peut-être abîmé la
structure adverse mais simplifier aussi
la tâche de Westley connait bien donc là
on a une position beaucoup plus
symétrique avec deux pions à l' dame
trois pions àroi les mêmes pièces un
cavalier chacun deux fous chacun mais
les noirs n'ont pas pu roquer évidemment
puisque le roi s'est retrouvé en D8 donc
on sent qu'il pourrait être peut-être
dans le viseur d'une tour blanche alors
est-ce que les Blancs ont envie de faire
grand rock pour mettre la tour en face
peut-être mais faudrait quand même
compter sur un coup comme fou prend à de
une fois que la Tour aura quitté cette
casin euh donc à regarder ce que ça
donnerait je pense que jouer H6
simplement pour contrôler la C G5 pour
pas avoir de cavalier sauter ici pour
s'en prendre à son fou ou peut-être de
fou débarquer ici et et clé noir tout ce
qu'il espère c'est finir son
développement et trouver un abri pour
son roi mais c'est pas si simple
disonsin on pourrait songer à un plan en
disant je peux faire tour C8 3 C7 et
partir là-bas mais le jour o on est en
C7 hop on va se prendre un coup des
Chacs comme fou F4 qui nous interdirait
d'aller en B8 donc ça on peut pas trop
le faire euh et venir en sinon on
aimerait bien bien sûr ça c'est un bel
abri mais où mettre ce fou où mettre ce
fou si on mettre le RO 7 si on vient en
7 avec le fou alors on prend la case du
roi si on VI en D6 on est en prise en C5
on peut se faire échanger et là la paire
de fou des blancs après l'échange il
restera avec donc deux fous contre un
sol et le cavalier bah pourrait parler
donc pas simple Magnus il VI jouer fou
C3 qui met une pression le long de cette
diagonale là et qui au passage bien sûr
interdit d'ailleurs le développement du
Fou F8 donc Wesley a des petits
problèmes à résoudre euh ça semble pas
insurmontable mais c'est pas tout simple
Magnus qui a une petite idée et qui va
demander quand même à Wesley de de jouer
avec précision dans cette partie alors
on pourrait s'attendre peut-être un coup
comme F6 peut-être pour mettre un mur
face à à ce fou euh un coup comme F6
voilà ne tape pas peut-être d'ailleurs
deuxème bien faait de ce coup coup ça
pourrait donner un abri au roi en F7 et
ça permettrait troisièmement de
développer ce fou alors c'est pas le
coup joué je vois par Wesley qui a joué
lui tour C8 dans cette position il place
sa tour sur une colonne ouverte donc
c'est quand même bien joué de sa part
euh pour l'instant il ne développe pas
sous il ne joue pas F6 il se le garde en
réserve mais peut-être qu'il aura mieux
en tête hein pourquoi pas peut-être
jouer F5 carrément ou alors aller cacher
le roi vers l'aile d'â on verra ce qu'il
a en
tête
toujours est-il à Magnus de voir comment
il va essayer de mettre la pression ici
s'il y arrive ou
pas tour C8 jouer peut-être qu' compte
faire roi C7 ro B8 je disais tout à
l'heure ce plan il me semblait sympa
mais le problème de RO C7 c'est que je
m'exposer un c fou F4 maintenant que le
Fou est en C3 la case 5 est couverte par
le cavalier donc pas for forcément
possible côté
blanc qu'est-ce que je pense de grand
rock puis tour B5 je sais pas trop
éimose euh grand ro pour les blancs ça
ça me va mais tour B5 c'est ça la ce B5
que j'ai mis en rouge il dur d'y aller
dessus et si tu tu as juste fait une
faute de frappe et que c'est D5 cela dit
j'ai le fou donc euh pas sûr de ce que
tu me dis mais je lirai au cas
où bon en tout cas tour C8 intéressant
de la part de westle qui active cette
tour le long de la colonne
C Magnus qui pourrait en profiter pour
développer ce fou hein qui ne joue pas
alors en2 en D3 et peut-être faire petit
rock ce grand rock on aimerait bien
évidemment ça Cresse visavis mais comme
je le disais tout à l'heure déjà ça va
aussi mettre le roi en vis-à-vis alors
ça autocor fou C3 mais surtout les Noirs
pourrai probablement essayer de s'en
prendre à ce pion à de alors après
regarder si on a le temps de faire autre
chose hein mais bon il a fait fou des TR
en tout cas il s'est développé et je
pense qu'il compte oker donc maintenant
à Wesley de voir est-ce qu'il veut faire
F6 amener le roi là-bas ou partir pour
se cacher vers B8 je pense que ce F6 il
devra le faire tôt ou tard il devra le
faire parce que sinon comment développer
ce s f ça c'est une question que à
laquelle il devra répondre
euh c'est c'est un souci parce que dès
que ce fou va partir il y aura G7 enem
prise
donc alors soit il compte faire tour G8
bouger le fou et voir après mais sinon
ce sera de toute façon la tour qui sera
passive à la défense du pion donc
j'imagine que FC c'est un coup plus ou
moins indispensable et que d'ailleurs
sur grand rock donc outre F PR2 qui bon
il faut regarder mais c'est très
probable que fou B5 fasse mal quand
même je pense que surtout ce que westla
en tête CIT de faire fou B4 çaurait
permis de développer son fou sans
crainte de per G7 perdre G7 puisquil y
avait le vis-à-vis sur le roi et le
cloage de sous C3 et ça ça aurait
solutionné ses problèmes parce que sur
un coup comme roi B1 pour enlever le
clouage on aurait pu échanger cacher le
roi ramener la tour en jeu et ça c'était
facile donc Magnus n'a pas autorisé tout
ça il a bien fait fou des TR et donc on
pose toujours une question noir comment
développer ce et
F donc Wesley
ouais qui doit solutionner ce petit
souci qui pour l'instant a l'air léger
et mineur mais si ça venait à
s'éterniser ça pourrait ne plus être si
simple et devenir des gros problèmes
donc cooup important je pense pour est
là
ici
il y a pas Bou from Vega from bon je
sais pas j'arrive pas dire ton nom ton
pseudo qui dit que F6 ça créit des trous
sur case blanche et ben je suis d'accord
avec toi mais mais en fait tu sais des
fois il faut faut accepter les choses et
des fois faire des concessions et aller
par ordre de priorité et la priorité
numéro 1 des Noirs c'est de développer
ce fou pour que la tour puisse jouer
sinon tu es en train de jouer sans ces
deux pièces d'ailleurs je vais les
mettre en rouge donc tu joues sans ces
deux pièces les blancs eux vont roquer
ils vont te mettre les tours au centre
ils vont qu' te créer des clouages des
menaces peut-être fou B5 et D6 et cetera
et tu vas être dépassé parce que il y a
cinq pièces qui vont jouer contre TR euh
partant de là c'est pas un scénario
vraiment envisageable alors à moins que
tu arrives vraiment à simplifier les
choses donc faut calculer hein c'était
une idée bon on peut regarder mais
concrètement moi je vois pas en fait ce
que les n peuvent vraiment faire euh ça
me semble trop dangereux du coup je
préfère ok je suis conscient que je fais
des trous mais en même temps c'est pas
comme si le cavalier allait me bondir
dessus du jour au lendemain puis faire
roil là roil là par disons petit rock je
fais roi7 ou ro8 je sais pas euh disons
que les Blancs fassent un coup naturelle
comme une tour au centre je mets mon roi
là une autre tour ici mon roi je le
trouve plutôt à l'abri maintenant il est
plus sur une colonne ouverte j'ai mon
fou qui blinde cette diagonale je crains
pas d'arriver en G6 je blinde tout bah
je peux me développer mettre la tour et
euh et finir les choses donc dans
l'idéal j'aima mieux de ne pas avoir de
trou même que mon pion soit là mais bah
les choses sont comme elles sont il faut
accepter de jouer par ordre de priorité
si sinon tu fait tu joueras jamais rien
tu feras jamais aucun échangeas ouis
mais mon fou je l'aime bien je peux pas
échanger mais mon pion je peux pas
l'avancer parce que bah en fait dès que
tu vas pousser un pion de toute façon tu
vas te dire ah bah je fais un trou là si
si tu avances euh c'était comme ça donc
en fait après tu peux plus jouer si tu
tu es que régi par des principes
généraux donc c'est bien de les avoir en
tête faut pas le faire par plaisir faut
être conscient de ce qu'on fait et être
vigilant pas faire des trous pour faire
des trous et si on peut éviter on évite
mais là en l'occurrence j'aurais du mal
à voir mieux que ça comme plan côté noir
après àoir F6 peut-être qu'au lieu de
rock peut-être les blancs peuvent déjà
bouger ce cavalier et pas me laisser
accéder à la casse avec le RO pour me
faire fou G6 et et que ça peut me poser
problème mais si je n'arrive pas à faire
F6 et mettre le roi là-bas j'ai pas de
bon setup côté noir euh parce qu'on
avait dit l'autre c'était d'aller cacher
le roi là-bas mais mon problème
là-dessus c'est que bon bah même une
fois que j'ai fait ça j'ai toujours pas
solutionné le problème de développer mon
fou donc les blancs peuvent venir au
centre avec leur tour ils peuvent même
jouer des coups comme k G3 cavalier H5
mettre pression là-bas et je suis bloqué
quoi donc voilà je sens en fait ce so
pas facile pour Wesley bon d'ailleurs il
a fait F6 voyez euh rock de Magnus et je
pense donc il va essayer d'amener le roi
là-bas alors soit par E7 soit par E8 ça
je sais pas enfin c'est aussi rapide he
l'un ou l'autre donc c'est pas une
histoire de vitesse et peut-être
d'ailleurs le 8 enfin Dison ça me semble
sécurisant de venir le 7 je défends
celui-là mais en en E7 en même temps je
bloque ce fou et je pe me prendre des
échecs donc c'est possible que 8 soit
mieux et d'ailleurs c'est ce que Westley
a
choisi et sinon en fait on me demandait
si on pouvait envisager un plan comme
tour G8 G6 fou G7 alors tu peux toujours
envisager hein mais tu vois quand tu
fais ça en train de me donner accès à
cette case donc faud que tu sois sûr que
tu es pas de problème si mon cavalier
arrive là et aussi quand tu pars avec
ton fou tu me laisses venir ici donc
l'absence deou D6 et aussi la poussée de
ce pion me laisse des cavaliers là donc
ça m'a l'air plus fragile que bah que du
coup c'est la construction qu' westle
qui qui est qui est cohérente je veux
dire non voilà il joue un peu comme
comme je pensais qu' qu'il devait faire
pas c'est bon sin ou pas pour lui mais
mais voilà
donc 38 jouer on va voir quand Magnus
compte essayer d'exploiter ses petits
petits avantages est-ce qu'il va essayer
de vite mettre les tours au centre mais
j'ai l'IM que les ns sont assez solides
est-ce qu'il va encore envoyer un pion
pour
appuyer sur ces petites cases blanches
un petit peu affaiblies on va
voir et rayenous qui demande Ludwig
c'est pasam on est d'accord non ce sont
deux personnes différentes euh Mazé
c'est Sébastien Mazé euh qui est qui est
grand maître et et
ludwiig juste peut-être tu as pu
confondre parce que il avait peut-être
les lunettes de soleil et cetera mais
mais non c'est pas c'est pas les mêmes
personnes et euh et
voilà en tout cas W là qui a plus ou
moins trouvé je pense
comment comment se mettre en
place
mon Magnus qui ouais qui
réfléchit
c'est pas facile hein de casser la
position noir là je dire je pense que
Wesley a pris une bonne décision et
qu'il a pas trop mal
géré le la phase
précédente en trouvant ce petit plan euh
après en fait si je me questionne sur ce
qu'il a fait il y a trois coups de ça
c'est ici je suis pas sûr en fait du
coup que H6 était très heureux peut-être
il aurait pu et dû faire F6 directement
si c'est pour jouer ce plan ça économisé
ce coup qui est pas très utile au
demeurant et donc ça va éviter un peu
les trous sur case blanche donc possible
possible si vous jouez cette variante
avec les noirs que F6 soit une
amélioration à vérifier de votre côté
analyser avec l'ordi mais sur ce que je
vois ça me semble plus logique que que
l'enchaînement H6 pour être forcé de
coups après de faire F6 ça m'a pas l'air
suffisamment grave pour les noirs pour
être vraiment mal mais il y a un petit
truc qui dit que peut-être c'était pas
ce qu'il y avait de de plus
précis comme Ditis Allen le cavalier à
deux cases de la C
G6 ça va être pas exploité ex exement en
fait un cavalier à deux cases d'ici
c'est très long il faut qu coups pour le
cavalier c'est c'est étonnant parce que
ça a pas l'air trop loin à vol d'oiseau
n'est pas un oiseau c'est un cavalier et
donc il lui faut qure coups pour y aller
par exemple 1 2 3 4 admettons il y a
d'autres trajets possibles mais c'était
juste pour pour pour montrer et donc un
cavalier ici serait beaucoup plus proche
d'une case comme B7 il aura besoin que
de deux coups alors que en distance
absolue bah ça a l'air plus loin que la
petite case G6 mais ouais des choses à
savoir ça pour sur le déplacement du
cavalier Magnus qui a reculé son fou
donc qui veut peut-être se diriger vers
H5
euh mais j'imagine qu'on peut quand même
faire ro F7 puisque sur fou H5 on pourra
jouer G6 chasser le fou une fois que
sera parti avoir le temps de se
développer et couvrir les cases alors
plutôt vers vers 7 toujours pareil pas
laisser la case D6
vulnérable après si ça l'embête ce fou
qui H5 il pourrait aussi songer à faire
H5 pour bah défendre défendre la case
avec sa tour en mettant le pion dessus
mais je sais pas je le sens moins j'irai
plus sur R F7 je tolérerai le fou si
jamais d'ailleurs voilà c'est ce qu'il a
joué si Magnus veut venir qu'il vienne
on fera on fera G6 et sinon bah vite
vite si possible un petit fou7 un
tourage D8 et on aura enfin sorti tout
le monde euh de leur case initiale et on
aura pu finir le développement important
le développement des échs évidemment il
faut que toutes les pièces puissent
participer au jeu avec avec
harmonie
et
ouais al Magnus ici qu'est-ce qu'il peut
faire bah je sais pas on sentaitc FO H5
c'était sûrement un coup qu'il aurait
voulu jouer mais comme je vous dis je
sens qu'on fait juste G6 le fou doit
repartir un F3 ou en E2 bon on va dire
F3 bah ça laisse le temps n de faire fou
E7 et les pions comme ça sont pas si
faible en fait au final donc je suis pas
sûr que ce soit une grande idée d'aller
perdre un temps pour pour faire F H5 du
coup ou bah peut-être il veut juste se
diriger vers la colonne D doubler les
tours essayer de
rentrer c'est pas mal peut-être tour HD1
parce que sur F 7 le coup j'ai Mo temps
faire pour me développer je laisse quand
même le temps à C D6 je dois prendre
tour prend et les blancs bah restent
avec une une paire de fou une paire de
fou que les noirs n'ont pas et en plus
peut-être fa H5 peut être une idée
puisque quand je ferai G6 mon roi sera
ce qu'on appelle en surcharge je dois
défendre ici je devrais défendre là donc
il aura fou pran donc ça peut être une
idée et là je peux être un peu moins Mo
bien donc tour HD1 à mon avis enfin
Tourche tour Fd1 c'est sûrement l'idée
de Magnus
h sur
quoi je sais pas exactement com on
couvre cette case D6 en
fait peut-être on peut faire k C5 comme
ça si k D6 je peux échanger et j'ai ce
coupl là je fais une fourchette alors je
vais pas gagner de matériel mais au
moins je me débarrasse de la paire de
fou je suis plutôt content on va voir en
tout cas Magnus il fait F4 euh je pense
qu' aurait été content d'avoir ce ce k
D6 et de gagner la paire de fou mais à
cause de ce k C5 c'est peut-être un
souci donc il fait F4 alors il veut
F5 une fois que le fou bouge fou H5 à
mon avis il veut cet enchaînement et
c'est c'est pas mal joué donc si on veut
éviter on peut penser à F5 mais je crois
que maintenant il aurait fut H5 puisque
G6 bah c'est plus trop une bonne idée
parce qu'il a la tour en vis-à-vis du
coup on se retrouve encore à balader le
loin mais on ne peut pas finir le
développement c'est toujours pareil donc
cette tour qui pourrait pas participer
au jeu euh c'est pénible donc F5 on va
dire qu'on qu'on refuse c'est pas trop
ce qu'on veut
G6 j'ai l'impression que cette fois on
s'affaiblit peut-être qu'on peut
repartir sur le plan de tout à l'heure
euh mais en un peu meilleur et oou
cavalier là pour casser donc G6 j'aime
pas trop F5 j'aime pas trop euh
ouais bah faut trouver euh mais des fois
faut faire comme ça faut faire des par
élimination et on finit par par tomber
sur le bon coup euh mais en tout cas les
deux manières direct d'éviter l'idée des
blancs de faire F5 euh ne fonctionne pas
peut-être il faudrait jouer un coup
comme fou C4 pour échanger celui-là euh
et pas laisser le ton blan d'enchaîner
F5 plus FO
H5 en tout cas Magnus qui trouve des des
petites idées pour maintenir la partie
vivante et pas laisser
euh pas laisser Wesley égaliser si
facilement o
réflexion parti de bon niveau hein je
dois dire alors certes il y a pas les
dames c'est pas une grande partie
d'attaque mais mais ça joue bien Magus
qui cherche les nuances pour créer des
problèmes à son adversaire
et et Wesley qui qui doit se montrer à
son tour précis pour pour sauver tout
ça sauver c'est un grand mot mais pour
défendre on va dire
égaliser
mais je dis pas si facile he il y a des
il y a des petites idées chez chez
Magnus com on peut pas stopper
mécaniquement
[Musique]
peut-être fou là peut-être
H5 H5 qui prend la case du Fou donc on
Tol F5 mais s'il peut pas enchaîner les
deux coups ensemble c'est déjà
probablement moins
[Musique]
grave mais
ouais pas c'est pas tout rose pas tout
simple peut-être qu'on peut juste
abandonner la per de fou et faire fouser
5 j' aime pas trop hein on voit la juge
la jauge qui monte mais oui parce que
bon ben il prend et j'ai ce problème de
de paire de fou qui qui a disparu et
c'est vrai que dans ce genre de
situation il y a toujours ce fou qui
vient de toute façon qui va me repousser
le roi par là-bas et ma tour ne va pas
participer au jeu donc ça aussi c'est
pas une option euh et ben c'est pas une
option mais c'est ce que Westley a joué
donc euh
[Musique]
ouais ben c'est la paire de fou pour
Magnus il va PIR travailler dessus paire
de fou donc c'est c'est de fous on voit
les Blancs ont de fous les Noirs ont un
fou un cavalier donc c'est pas le même
rapport matériel et c'est une position
normalement qui favorise clairement la
paire de fou parce que c'est une
position ouverte où il y a trois
colonnes qui séparent les deux ailes
donc trois colonnes c'est beaucoup ça
veut dire en fait les fous il y a pas de
trafic au milieu il y a pas des pions
qui bloquent les diagonales et aussi
s'il y avait encore un pion ici par
exemple le cavalier pourrait venir se
planter en D5 serait indélogeable grâce
au pion et donc ce cavalier au centre
contrôlera des cases bloquerait des
diagonales et gênerait
donc ça pourrait être pénible bon l'ordi
n'aime pas le coup mais bon quoi de plus
naturel que de mettre la tour en D1 donc
moi je peux pas critiquer le coup de
Magnus qui m'a l'air très bien et euh je
dirais que Magnus a quand même un vrai
espoir de gager cette partie c'est son
genre de position où il peut travailler
techniquement sans risque euh il est
très à l'aise là-dedans et euh il va
pouvoir peut-être faire jouer toutes à
mastria dans les finales et ce genre de
de position wesle qui va vraiment devoir
défendre pas facile pour lui là il les
deux joueurs approche des 3 minutes
chacun moment important de ce match et
de cette finale et même de cette saison
je dois dire de champion
chestour fou D4 il a attaqué la tour qui
est parti se réfugier en A5 euh je
m'attends un coup de recul peut-être
mais pourquoi pas en à 5 il vient
attaquer ce pion il vient aussi couvrir
à 7 si jamais il veut bouger son
cavalier je pense qu'il voudrait un jour
se rediriger vers le centre peut-être
euh ou peut-être faire un fou C4 je sais
pas à voir euh à voir ce cavalier peut
venir au centre mais faut pas oublier
que ce fou peut se faire chasser et
après peut-être des clouages arriveront
et
cetera donc donc on va
voir tour à 5 Magnus qui commence à
descendre vers 2 minutes
30 B4 jouer les qure jolis coups parce
qu'en fait l'idée c'est que ça enfin ça
donne le pion c'est le but c'est pas de
donner le pion mais je pense qu'en fait
le problème de prendre c'est que ça met
la tour sur la même diagonale que le roi
et qu'on va
avoir des soucis là-dessus alors cela
dit je pensais qu'on avait F5 et que ça
va être pénible mais tu reprends on
attaque le fou euh est-ce que c'est
juste tour F2 ou il veut F H5 en fait je
suis pas trop sûr de tour prend à 2
euh HM tour A2 fou
H5 le RO de cas on va dire qu'il vont G8
on peut prendre prendre mais déjà on per
une qualitéil y a am minima tour D8 3 H7
F G6
et il y a peut-être des F5 bon je la
montre sans les flèches parce que ça
fait trop de trucs mais donc il y a
échec disons qu'on bouge le roi il prend
on prend et comme je vous dis à minima
on peut faire tour échec le roi n'a
qu'une case de fite et et jouer fou G6
et et aller gagner une qualité alors a
priori c'est pas ça qui gagne l'ordi va
défendre avec fou ici c'est VI que je
peux pas courir avec T F2 enfin je peux
mais il y a échec je dois redescendre il
remonte bon est nul euh
mais alors pas tour D8 mais l'ordi veut
peut-être F5 pour aller mettre le fou là
et mettre un peu un clou dans le
cercueil du roi noir pour aller le
matter sur la 8e rangée en tout cas ce
n'a pas été joué mais c'était
intéressant à voir pourquoi pas prendre
donc il revient en D5 mais j'imagine que
ce ce coup n'était pas très heureux
étant donné qu'il est en train de se
faire chasser de partout et là ça y est
l'ordi déteste la jauge est monté à fond
euh l'ordi voulait redescendre la tour
par là-bas alors tour B5 euh pourquoi
c'est si grave euh mais bon on sent
Wesley qui qui a pris un peu l'eau là
qui navigue sa tour à droite à gauche la
tour elle est plus ou moins fermée après
un coup comme fou 2 enfin pas plus ou
moins elle est complètement fermée
d'ailleurs je dois dire sur fou 2 et on
pourrait peut-être voir la fin de ce
match si Magnus arrive à
bah à concrétiser son avantage il n est
plus très loin euh voilà tour est
enfermé sur fou 2 on pourrait faire kc3
en disant tiens je contre-attaque les
deux mais mais si je prends la tour vous
avez pas le temps de prendre ici parce
que je reprends et je resterai avec un
fou en plus donc c'est une qualité
d'avance he qui se dessine pour Magnus
alors peut-être contre un pion ça laisse
de micro chance à westle de défendre
mais le jeu est quand même très ouvert
il y a beaucoup de colonnes et je crois
pas trop ces chances euh vraiment fou 2
a l'air l'air d'être un bon coup alors
peut-être qu' a encore mieux on verra en
tout cas fou 2 a été joué par Magnus
westle qui sacrifie la qualité alors il
est pas allé prendre C5 il a fait CER C3
il espère il espère récupér quelque
chose sur la route un
échange fou G5 G6 il y a deux pièces
attaquer mais la tour peut bouger pour
attaquer ce cavalier probablement D3
plutôt puisquen C1 il y aurait qu' pr à
2 qui attaquerait encore la tour
euh qui pourrait jouer tour D3 et Magnus
qui a l'air de s'envoler vers un nouveau
succès un nouveau sacre dans sa carrière
Wesley qui tente une enfilade avec fou
C4 mais ça laisse peut-être tour D7
échec tout ça
euh ement le coup que Magnus va choisir
d'ailleurs ce ce tour
des7 voilà c'est jouer échec au roi le
roi monte on peut faire échec ici parce
que donc la tour est attaqué le Fou est
attaqué mais en faisant échec avec la
tour on enlève une pièce attaquée et
après le fou pourra reculer voir
peut-être faire une attaque de mat
contre ce roi noir qui commence à être
vraiment dans de Sal DRP il peut
peut-être aller en F7 il peut aller en
F5 mais il faud compter sur un coup
comme
G4 et puis il faut noter aussi que ces
deux pièces là sont liigné et qu'un coup
comme toursé un peut vite arriver pour
attaquer tout le monde voilà c'est
joué je crois qu'il va falloir peut-être
faire cavalier de on va échanger ou
prendre ce fou mais il y aura t reprend
cavalier la position noire qui
s'effondre complètement cavalier E4
attaque la tour D6 bon juste l'espoir de
West et que Magnus n'a plus que 16
secondes donc il peut espérer peut-être
un une gaffe à ce moment là mais la
position l'air simple quand même et non
abandon de Wesley et ben écoutez c'est
fini victoire ire de Magnus dans cette
4e partie et dans ce match Magnus qui
aura été quand même au-dessus dans ces
deux jours j'ar pile pile pour la fin
j'ai suivi ton live Fab cette paire de
fou paire de fou qui a parlé qui a parlé
et Magnus qui s'impose donc dans ce
speed chess dans ce champion chest
champion chestour bah belle victoire de
Magnus beau champion n mondial qui a
encore fait parler sa la poudre
ouais
de se quitter mais surtout de d'aller
peut-être sur le live oui on va vous
mettre un un Raed ouais pour aller voir
les interview et la fin de ce superbe
tournoi peut-être un un trophée remis
euh je sais qu'il y a des trucs sympas à
gagner là le display de signé par les
finalistes et cetera donc oui on vous
reconseille vivement d'aller sur la
chaîne officielle et euh et de suivre la
fin de cet événement exceptionnel euh la
remise des trophées les interviews
célébration je ne sais pas on verra on
verra Fabien en tout cas merci à tous
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve dès la fin
du mois pour les championnats du monde
de Blitz et rapide ciao tout le monde
ciao